That sounds good in my ears.
听起来很不错。
We ambushed you with this.
我们用这个给你搞了个突袭。
It's got a little of the white lotus shriek in there.
里面还有点《白莲花度假村》那种尖叫的感觉。
Yeah, I'm so pleased.
是啊，我太高兴了。
This is a remix of my song NYC, which is the theme song to how we made your mother, which is the show we're on right now.
这是我那首《NYC》的混音版，也是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的主题曲，也就是我们现在正在录的这个节目的剧。
And Alec decided to surprise me and drop my buddy Jeremiah Dunlap, one of the producers of my album.
Alec决定给我个惊喜，放出了我哥们儿Jeremiah Dunlap的作品，他也是我专辑的制作人之一。
That song did these remixes that are incredible.
那首歌做的这些混音简直太棒了。
And that's NYC, you know, I was thinking like NYC, as I wrote it, is kind of like the perfect walking around New York music, that's like driving through LA music, don't you think?
这就是《NYC》，你知道，我写的时候就在想，这首歌就像是那种完美的在纽约漫步的音乐，就像那种开车穿过洛杉矶的音乐一样，你不觉得吗？
Yeah, driving through LA, but thinking of NYC, walking for New York.
是啊，开车穿过洛杉矶，但心里想的是纽约，为了纽约而漫步。
Winding my wallet at dusk.
黄昏时分，我漫无目的地走着。
Yes, definitely, definitely.
是的，绝对是，绝对是。
Well, thanks for playing that, Alec.
好吧，谢谢你放这首歌，Alec。
Did you have more to add, Ken?
Ken，你还有什么要补充的吗？
No, well, we did we had a little email volley of we should and bus Josh with this just one random episode because we both Liked it so much this came out a few weeks ago.
没，其实我们之前通过邮件商量过，说应该在某个随机的剧集里给Josh一个惊喜，因为我们俩都太喜欢这首歌了，它是几周前发布的。
Awesome.
太棒了。
Everybody go check that out on job We're called the skeleton and spirit remixes.
大家都去听听看，我们叫它《Skeleton and Spirit》混音版。
It's a couple.
有好几首。
There's a few of them, right?
有好几首，对吧？
Two tracks learning and NYC and two of each they sound great right the bravo bravo to Jeremiah really really well done It said they sounds like totally different songs, but the same song really successful remixed.
两首曲子《Learning》和《NYC》，每首有两个版本，听起来很棒，对吧？向Jeremiah致敬，真的做得非常好，听起来完全像是不同的歌，但又是同一首歌，非常成功的混音。
Yeah, he he really It was just something I asked him to do a remix of learning because it was something I always thought would be fun.
是啊，他真的……我只是让他给《Learning》做个混音，因为我一直觉得那会很有趣。
And then he just surprised me with these four tracks that I'm delighted by.
然后他就用这四首曲子给了我惊喜，我非常喜欢。
So we were really happy to release them.
所以我们很高兴能发布它们。
And we're really happy to be here with you all for one of my actual How I Met Your Mother favorite episodes, Areva Derci Fierro from season two.
我们也很高兴能和大家一起回顾我最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧集之一，第二季的《Arrivederci, Fiero》。
This is by the way the podcast where me, Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, co-creator of How I met your mother with Carter Bayes.
顺便说一下，这是我和Josh Radner，以及与Carter Bays共同创作了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的Craig Thomas一起做的播客。
We go back through the show.
我们正在重温这部剧。
We can't even believe how far along we are into season two.
我们甚至不敢相信我们已经录到第二季这么后面了。
This is episode 17 of season two.
这是第二季的第17集。
A Riva D'Archefiero written by, I believe, Chris Harris.
《Arrivederci, Fiero》，编剧我记得是Chris Harris。
Chris Harris, a classic Chris Harris episode.
Chris Harris，经典的Chris Harris剧集。
Classic Chris Harris episode.
经典的Chris Harris剧集。
Alec, when did this episode air?
Alec，这一集是什么时候播出的？
On February 26th in the year 2007.
2007年2月26日。
That sweet 19 years ago, that's true.
天哪，19年前了，是真的。
That's true.
是真的。
Lucky number 19.
幸运数字19。
That shouldn't hurt every time, every single time that hurts.
每次听到这个数字都让人心痛，每一次都心痛。
When we say the day, oh, you think it would get lost, but it doesn't.
当我们说出日期时，哦，你以为它会被遗忘，但并没有。
Yeah.
是啊。
How is it that long ago?
怎么会过去那么久了？
It's so strange because some episodes that we've been talking about, I have very dim, if not amnesiac memories.
这太奇怪了，因为我们谈论过的一些剧集，我的记忆非常模糊，甚至像失忆了一样。
Right.
没错。
Some of them have been memory-hold.
有些已经被封存在记忆里了。
For some reason, this episode is incredibly vivid in my memory, both what happens, what the jokes were, and the actual filming of it.
但出于某种原因，这一集在我的记忆中非常清晰，无论是剧情、笑话，还是实际拍摄的过程。
I remember very vividly.
我记得非常清楚。
I don't know why that is.
我不知道为什么。
I mean, maybe- It's very visceral.
我是说，也许……它非常深刻。
I mean, part of it is that you're playing this other TED in so much of the episode.
我是说，部分原因是你在这集的大部分时间里都在扮演另一个Ted。
You're playing college.
你在扮演大学时期的Ted。
This is the most college TED in any episode today.
这是目前为止所有剧集中最“大学版”的Ted。
This is the most college TED we get.
这是我们见过的最大学生的Ted。
Yeah.
是啊。
I think that if there's a college TED iconic line, it's, you know, my parents live in Ohio.
我觉得如果有一句大学版Ted的标志性台词，那就是：“我父母住在俄亥俄州，我活在当下。”
I live in the moment.
我活在当下。
Yes.
没错。
It's one of my, well, I rarely jump in to take credit.
这是我……好吧，我很少跳出来邀功。
I think that was my line.
我觉得那是我的台词。
And I- That was your, I know it was yours.
而且我……那是你的，我知道是你的。
That is one of my favorite Ted lines that I've ever, that I've ever wrote.
那是我写过的我最喜欢的Ted台词之一。
And it's for a past Ted, it's not for Ted.
而且那是给过去的Ted的，不是给现在的Ted的。
It's a meme too, you can, you can meme that.
它也成了梗，你可以把它做成表情包。
It is me, it has been memeed out.
确实是，它已经被做成表情包了。
I'm always honored by that, that's a good, it is a great Chris Harris episode, that one, that one little thing was mine, maybe I got a few other little ones, but that one is one of my favorites.
我对此一直感到很荣幸，那确实是Chris Harris写得很好的一集，那一小句是我的，也许我还有其他几句，但那一句是我的最爱之一。
It's just been your performance of it.
这全靠你的表演。
It also kicks off like that, like that's the flashback, that's the beginning of the flashback where we meet college Ted, you realize we're gonna be with college Ted a bunch in the episode.
它也是这样开场的，那是闪回，是大学版Ted出场的闪回，你意识到我们这集要和大学版Ted待很久。
And it's just such a great way into like, this is who Ted was in college.
这真是进入“这就是大学时期的Ted”状态的好方法。
We're gonna see a whole adventure with this guy.
我们要和这个家伙一起经历一场冒险。
Is this the introduction of college?
这是大学版Ted的首次登场吗？
I feel like we've seen him before, right?
我觉得我们之前见过他，对吧？
We've seen him before, we've glimpsed him before, but we really go, we go on a literal journey with him in this one, which I love.
我们见过他，之前瞥见过，但这一集我们真的和他一起踏上了一段真正的旅程，我喜欢这一点。
I mean, you have a lot of fun playing college Ted.
我是说，你扮演大学版Ted时玩得很开心。
It's very palpable, how much fun you're having.
你玩得有多开心，显而易见。
You know, when we would do like mask and clown work at NYU and drama school, there's a thing like you put on like a mask or you develop a clown where it gives you like there's a kind of, it's both obscures something about your physicality and also reveals something about your physicality.
你知道，当我们在纽约大学和戏剧学院做面具和丑角练习时，有一种说法是，当你戴上某种面具或塑造一个丑角时，它既掩盖了你身体的某些特质，也揭示了你身体的某些特质。
And you can see when people, even people who are not particularly like comedic actors, if they like quote unquote, find their clown, everything they do is hilarious and amazing.
你可以看到，当人们，即使是那些不是特别擅长喜剧的演员，如果他们“找到了自己的丑角”，他们所做的一切都会变得滑稽而精彩。
And I feel like when I put on the college Ted wig, much like Barney putting on like Barista Barney.
我觉得当我戴上大学版Ted的假发时，就像Barney戴上咖啡师Barney的装备一样。
It's kind of an exchange to his whole walk, and his whole rhythm.
这改变了他的整个步态和节奏。
My language, totally different.
我的语言，完全不同。
And when I would put on the college, Ted Wig, something came out of me that was just different.
当我戴上大学版Ted的假发时，我身上就会流露出一种完全不同的东西。
It was just a different speed.
那是一种不同的节奏。
Yes, yes, you become a different person.
是的，是的，你变成了另一个人。
It's still the same guy, there's still, but it's brilliant.
他还是同一个人，但这种表演太精彩了。
I love you as college dad, the spectacles that turn out to be decorative.
我喜欢你演的大学版Ted，那些其实是装饰用的眼镜。
Yeah, we always used to joke, I don't remember who I would joke with.
是啊，我们以前常开玩笑，我不记得是和谁开的玩笑了。
maybe Chris Harris or you, but in high school, Ted had like pretty straight hair.
也许是Chris Harris或者你，但在高中时，Ted的头发还挺直的。
He gets to Wesley and for some reason he has this massively curly.
他到了卫斯理大学，不知为何头发就变得超级卷。
It was like, was the humidity and scene in Wesley in 1993 or whatever they were in school?
就像是1993年在卫斯理大学时，因为潮湿导致的？
Yeah, let's go with that theory.
好吧，我们就用这个理论吧。
That's right.
没错。
Ted was using a lot of product in high school, said I'm going on at your Allen College and went back to the even more product later.
Ted在高中时用了不少定型产品，到了大学又用了更多。
But he also, it's my spectacles that he was wearing decorative spectacles.
但他还有那些眼镜，他戴的是装饰性眼镜。
Oh, the decorative spectacles.
哦，那些装饰性眼镜。
And just so insecure, can't handle not being as good at Zitchdog, just gets dumped by Karen, tries to play like it was mutual.
而且他那么不自信，无法接受自己在“Zitchdog”游戏中表现不好，被Karen甩了，还试图装作是双方自愿的。
That lines you with can't where it's like, who knows?
那句台词……谁知道呢？
She brought it up, but he was totally mutual.
是她提出来的，但他说是双方自愿的。
Who's no fun now, Karen, when he just says to get off the highway, he likes them over.
“现在谁没意思了，Karen？”当他让对方下高速公路时，他喜欢他们。
He's going through so much.
他经历了太多。
That's why you're very loose, and you have so much fun because he's just in total turmoil, he doesn't know who he is yet, and you just get, I don't know, it unlocks something in your performance where you're just having so much fun with it.
这就是为什么你演得很放松，玩得很开心，因为他正处于极度的混乱中，他还不知道自己是谁，这解锁了你的表演，让你玩得很尽兴。
He's such a lovable mess, but he's also like, I love him, I love college debt.
他是个可爱的烂摊子，但我爱他，我爱大学版Ted。
I do too, I do remember, it's funny, we're doing that snowstorm, me and Jason, that's on the stage, right?
我也爱，我记得，很有趣，我们在拍那场暴风雪戏，我和Jason，是在舞台上，对吧？
We're not outside.
我们不在外面。
Yeah, that's on the stage.
是的，那是在摄影棚里。
It's all created and just, you know, whenever we'd be driving, you'd have George just rocking the car.
一切都是创造出来的，你知道，每当我们开车时，乔治就会在那儿摇晃车身。
Yes, just moving the car a lot.
是的，就是不停地晃动车子。
It's so weird.
太奇怪了。
That must have been so weird to act in that situation where there's just like black out all around you.
在那种周围一片漆黑的情况下表演，一定很奇怪吧。
You're seeing a crew guy like like leveraging a car up and down.
你会看到一个工作人员像是在上下撬动车子。
Some kind of device moving it.
用某种装置在移动它。
Or was it just pressing on the side of like, I don't know, I forgot if they had like a device to do that.
还是说他们只是在旁边按压，我不知道，我忘了他们是否有专门的装置来做这件事。
they'd have like a, like literally like a, like a, like a big piece of wood.
他们会用一个，真的就像是一个，一个大木板。
Yeah.
对。
And the car was on and become like, like, pull like levied or whatever, like a, like a, yeah, where it was called.
车子就在上面，然后像杠杆一样被撬动，或者别的什么，反正就是那样。
And he would just be pressing on it to make the car look like it was trying to act while that's, I mean, it was one of those things you always felt like this feels a, this feels very fake.
他就在那儿按压，让车子看起来像是在行驶，我的意思是，那总是让你觉得这感觉很假。
I feel I see the seams and the, I mean, it's called poor man's process.
我感觉我看到了破绽，我的意思是，这叫“穷人拍摄法”。
Poor man's process.
穷人拍摄法。
Cause you're not even bothering to do like a blue screen behind.
因为你甚至懒得在后面弄个蓝幕。
You're just making it very dark and just saying, all right, that's it.
你只是把它弄得很暗，然后说，好吧，就这样了。
But then you're gonna fill it in like it always and the car scene's always looked pretty good They look good fill them in and they'd look they look good or no the lighting You know they just like throw headlights at night Yeah, so you'd see some headlights going by you'd see some wind you'd see like there's enough to sort of fake out your brain But it's it is they call it poor man's process that for those nighttime shoots It's not yeah really weirdly unsophisticated.
但之后你会把它填补起来，就像总是做的那样，车里的场景看起来总是相当不错，它们看起来很好，填补起来看起来很棒，或者不，灯光，你知道，他们只是在晚上打上车灯，是的，所以你会看到一些车灯经过，你会看到一些风，你会看到，这足以欺骗你的大脑，但这就是他们所说的“穷人拍摄法”，对于那些夜间拍摄来说，它确实非常简陋。
I do remember in the snowstorm Jason like pushing it with me he didn't do anything gross but he held me like very tight.
我确实记得在暴风雪那场戏里，杰森推着我，他没做什么恶心的事，但他抱我很紧。
Like he, like he, Jason was, Jason and Neil are not breakers as much.
就像他，杰森，杰森和尼尔不太容易笑场。
I mean, Neil was the, as we said, he has the stoniest visage.
我的意思是，尼尔，正如我们所说，他有一张最严肃的脸。
Total ninja.
绝对的忍者。
Yeah.
是的。
It just never breaks.
他从来不会笑场。
But Jason would try to get you to break.
但杰森会试图让你笑场。
Yeah.
是的。
And I do remember, I think it's on the blooper reel.
我确实记得，我想那是在花絮里。
I think there's, there's a number of where he got you.
我想有几次他确实让你笑场了。
where he got me in this.
他确实让我笑场了。
Yeah, so I have a strong, I just have a strong memory.
是的，所以我有一个深刻的记忆。
And this is one, this is not quite a mystery episode.
这一集不完全是一个悬疑集。
This is what I call filling in the lore episodes, right?
这就是我所说的“填充背景故事”的剧集，对吧？
Yeah, it is.
是的，确实是。
It's filling in the lore.
这是在填充背景故事。
And it's kind of, there's another episode coming up soon called, or maybe in season three, like how I met everybody else.
而且，很快还有另一集，或者可能是在第三季，叫“我是如何遇见其他人的”。
Or how I met everyone else, which it's just, yeah, it's filling in, however, like this is the story of how they became best friends.
或者“我是如何遇见其他所有人的”，这只是，是的，它在填充背景，这就是他们如何成为好朋友的故事。
They were not friends when they got in that car.
他们上那辆车时还不是朋友。
And then there, it was a life altering journey.
然后那是一段改变人生的旅程。
It's true, this episode doesn't really move the present day story forward at all, but it fills in the gaps in this way that makes you love the characters more.
没错，这一集并没有真正推动当下的故事发展，但它以一种让你更爱这些角色的方式填补了空白。
We see two best friendships for him, and we see Barney learn to drive.
我们看到了他两段最好的友谊，也看到了巴尼学习开车。
Those are all momentous things.
这些都是重大的事情。
That's the log line, we're getting to it later, but that's the log line.
这就是梗概，我们稍后再谈，但这就是梗概。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小歌，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York, or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
比如，“我30岁了，不敢在纽约开车”，或者“为什么我倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？”
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
at wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
在任何你收听播客的地方或访问hyperfixedpod.com即可收听。
And now?
现在呢？
It must also be fun in the writer's room when you're like, okay, Lily and Robin getting Thai food all over the fiero and then coming up with this big lie to cover it.
在编剧室里一定也很有趣，当你们说，好吧，莉莉和罗宾把泰餐弄得满车都是，然后编造这个大谎言来掩盖它。
It's not enough for a B story or even a C story.
这不足以支撑一个B故事甚至C故事。
It's just like a little.
这就像一个小插曲。
It's mini vignette.
迷你小品。
It's a little vignette.
这是一个小插曲。
It's a vignette and even Barney Driving, which gets a little more airtime, it's like, It's not enough, but you can, when you're just doing these filling in the lore episodes, you can hit them.
这是一个小插曲，甚至巴尼开车那段，虽然戏份多一点，但它，这还不够，但当你做这些填充背景的剧集时，你可以把它们串起来。
And the mini, mini, mini stories like the suicidal cat.
还有那些迷你小故事，比如自杀的猫。
Yeah, it's the quick pops.
是的，就是快速闪过的片段。
It's great, it's great, because yeah, you normally would have that idea and you go, oh, that's funny, but it can't be a whole episode, so forget it.
这很棒，真的很棒，因为通常你会想到那个点子，然后说，哦，那很有趣，但它不能成为一整集，所以就算了。
Coming up with the right kind of structure where you can fit in these little gem kind of mini stories is so great.
想出一种合适的结构，能把这些小宝石般的迷你故事塞进去，真是太棒了。
And I just wanna say before I forget, the story of Barney's super low speed car accident and quotes really happened to Chris Harris, the writer of this episode.
在我忘记之前我想说，巴尼那场超低速车祸的故事，确实发生在这一集的编剧克里斯·哈里斯身上。
Chris Harris, when he was being taught how to drive with his dad, had basically exactly that experience with a dog came and Chris had like a two mile an hour like freak out.
克里斯·哈里斯在他爸爸教他开车时，基本上经历了完全一样的事情，一只狗跑过来，克里斯以每小时两英里的速度惊慌失措。
He didn't realize that he could just stop and sort of pulled off into some hedges.
他没意识到他可以直接停下来，结果冲进了树篱里。
Like really was the same exact story.
真的就是完全一样的故事。
It's so stupid.
太蠢了。
I'm continually amazed on this podcast when we break that stuff down where the parts of the episodes that are true, you would never, you would never even guess.
在这个播客里，当我们剖析那些真实发生的部分时，我总是感到惊讶，你根本猜不到。
like that seems invented and stupid.
比如那看起来像是编造的蠢事。
But Chris Harris was like, now I had the least exciting car accident of all time.
但克里斯·哈里斯说，我经历了史上最无聊的车祸。
We're like, that's going in there.
我们说，那要写进去。
It's like the marathoner whose legs wouldn't work.
就像那个腿动不了的马拉松选手一样。
Exactly.
没错。
It's like that's the true part of that episode, which is insane.
这就是那一集真实的部分，太疯狂了。
Yeah.
是的。
I noticed like when I look back, even got 19 years later, like I do remember, I can tell when I'm actually laughing, you know?
我注意到当我回顾时，即使是19年后，我确实记得，我能分辨出我什么时候是真的在笑，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you laughing or not seeing with Neil?
你是真的在笑，还是在和尼尔演戏？
I am genuinely laughing.
我是发自内心地在笑。
It seemed very genuine.
看起来非常真实。
It caught my eye.
引起了我的注意。
I was like, that seems like Josh's real laugh because you're saying insane shit.
我当时想，那看起来像是乔什真实的笑声，因为你在说些疯狂的话。
You're saying like, throw me the, throw me the idol and I'll throw me the whip.
你在说，把那个偶像扔给我，把鞭子扔给我。
You're like holding in the out of Jones.
你就像是在模仿印第安纳·琼斯。
There's like, the stuff you're yelling in that scene is really weird and we like, you can't really even, it's almost inaudible, but you're laughing that whole time and it's really genuine away.
你在那场戏里喊的东西真的很奇怪，我们，你几乎都听不清，但你一直在笑，而且笑得非常真实。
Well, I was laughing because Neil was just making me laugh.
嗯，我笑是因为尼尔一直在逗我笑。
Like he was just being, it's so ridiculous.
他当时的样子太荒谬了。
Can I just throw in that Marmalady boy just says, I need to know, was Josh Radner really laughing his ass off for the most hilarious performance?
我能插一句吗，Marmalady Boy问，我需要知道，乔什·拉德诺当时是真的笑得前仰后合吗，因为那表演太搞笑了？
You were definitely caught by a couple of bars, yeah.
你确实被几个点戳中了，是的。
But it's great, it's great.
但这很棒，真的很棒。
I think that's a huge part of the show is super power.
我认为这是这部剧的一大超能力。
They would capture those moments on that.
他们会捕捉到那些瞬间。
Like you guys are, there's funny people that are making you laugh, like you should laugh.
就像你们，有有趣的人在逗你笑，你应该笑出来。
That's the 10 would laugh.
那是第10次笑场。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
And again, that was the thing we decided early on.
再说一次，那是我们很早就决定的事情。
Like you should laugh when it's laugh.
你应该在好笑的时候笑出来。
like these are funny, light-hearted, you know, it's, we had enough serious stuff, but like, it's funny, funny stuff happens on the show and the characters that know that it's funny.
这些都是有趣、轻松的，你知道，我们已经有足够严肃的内容了，但剧里确实发生了有趣的事情，角色们也知道这很有趣。
And seeing Barney be that helpless is, would make to laugh.
看到巴尼那么无助，会让人想笑。
Like, Barney puts up such bravado and then when you get a peek under the hood, so to speak, like, yeah, unintended, I guess, it's funny.
巴尼总是装出一副虚张声势的样子，当你窥见他的内心时，可以说，是的，无意冒犯，这很有趣。
Well, it's also, it's a great thing to give Barney because again, it's like, he needs regular dings in his armor, like he needs to be dented of.
嗯，这也是给巴尼的一个好东西，因为再说一次，他需要盔甲上有一些凹痕，他需要被挫挫锐气。
regular, yes, regularly scheduled takedowns, so it's not just pure male toxicity.
定期的，没错，定期安排的打击，所以这不仅仅是纯粹的男性毒性。
I do have to say that, Jordana, my wife found it hilarious, the driving stuff, but also, cause he says, I grew up in the city, you know, and I, so I don't know if a lot of people know this, and I didn't really learn this until I got to college and met all these New York City kids, and Alec, I don't know, you grew up in New York City, right?
我不得不说，乔丹娜，我妻子觉得这很有趣，关于开车的事情，但也因为他说，我在城市里长大，你知道，我，所以我不知道有多少人知道这一点，我直到上大学遇到所有这些纽约市的孩子才知道，亚历克，我不知道，你在纽约市长大的，对吧？
Are you, did you know, did you learn to drive at 16?
你是，你知道吗，你16岁学会开车了吗？
No, no, I learned late, maybe late 17s.
不，不，我学得晚，大概17岁晚些时候。
And by the way, at night in Manhattan is how I learned, which was completely insane.
顺便说一句，我是在曼哈顿的晚上学的，那简直太疯狂了。
Wow, yeah.
哇，是啊。
Well, that's rare because a lot of New York City kids as sophisticated as they might be growing up in this huge city, driving is one of the common things that a lot of New York City kids like, they don't get it so much later if at all.
嗯，这很罕见，因为很多纽约市的孩子，尽管他们在这么大的城市里长大可能很老练，但开车是很多纽约市孩子觉得很普通的事情，他们很久以后才学会，甚至根本不会。
There's a bunch of people who grew up in New York City that are like, yeah, I don't drive.
有一群在纽约市长大的人会说，是的，我不开车。
That's a very real thing.
那是非常真实的事情。
I know people in their 30s and 40s who still don't really drive in Maine and Maine ever.
我认识一些30多岁和40多岁的人，他们仍然不在缅因州开车，从来都不开。
And in your city, it's very common.
在你们的城市，这很常见。
Jordana told me she got her driver's license at 21 simply so she'd have the ID to get into bars.
乔丹娜告诉我，她21岁才拿到驾照，仅仅是为了有身份证件去酒吧。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是啊。
Like that was why she did.
就像那是她这么做的原因。
And then she didn't drive again until her 30s.
然后直到30多岁她才再次开车。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, I totally believe it.
是的，我完全相信。
I totally were back on my way if maybe somewhere in her 20s she got her license, like maybe because we were moving to LA.
我完全记得，如果她在20多岁时拿到了驾照，可能是因为我们要搬到洛杉矶。
But I think it was when I was before that, But she really was not a confident driver.
但我认为那是在那之前，但她确实不是一个自信的司机。
She never grew up in Brooklyn.
她从来没有在布鲁克林长大。
The only flaw with that, and I'm so glad we did that story because it is a very real city thing.
那个故事唯一的瑕疵，我很高兴我们做了那个故事，因为它是一个非常真实的城市现象。
Barney did grow up on Staten Island where you definitely would drive.
巴尼确实是在斯塔滕岛长大的，在那里你肯定会开车。
You would drive, yeah, yeah, yeah.
你会开车的，是啊，是啊，是啊。
We were watching it last night.
我们昨晚在看它。
I was like, oh, that's a slayed flaw in like trying to totally nail what the city kid thing is, but it's close enough.
我就想，哦，那是一个小瑕疵，试图完全捕捉到城市孩子的特点，但已经很接近了。
He's still kind of a city kid.
他仍然算是个城市孩子。
He took the train.
他坐火车。
Yeah.
是啊。
But yeah, that's a very real NYC thing.
但是的，那是非常真实的纽约市现象。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then when we were spending some time in LA, when I still had my place in LA, Um, she, she was, she was like, I'm going to use this time.
然后当我们在洛杉矶待了一段时间时，当我还在洛杉矶有住处时，嗯，她，她当时，她说，我要利用这段时间。
And she, she had this driving instructor, Pirla, shout out to Pirla.
然后她，她有位驾驶教练，皮拉，向皮拉致敬。
And she did 24 hours of driving lessons in, she would do two 12, two hour lessons.
她进行了24小时的驾驶课程，她会做两次12小时，两次两小时的课程。
And, uh, and she's a pretty good drive.
而且，呃，她开车开得相当不错。
She still gets nervous, but she's, she's, she's got herself up to speed.
她仍然会紧张，但她，她，她已经跟上进度了。
So that's just last year, like, or in the last year, like the last couple of years.
所以那只是去年，或者在过去的一年里，就像过去几年里。
The last couple of years.
过去几年。
That's, that's crazy.
那，那太疯狂了。
Yeah.
是啊。
That's crazy.
那太疯狂了。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's true.
这是真的。
I'm glad to be captured.
我很高兴被捕捉到。
I love only capture those very real New York details that yeah people from other places like no Why wouldn't you you drive you learn to drive the second you can learn to drive?
我喜欢只捕捉那些非常真实的纽约细节，是的，来自其他地方的人会说，不，你为什么不，你开车，你一能开车就学开车？
It's like no no no there's no reason to drive I learned to drive on a stick shift like that's how my serious My dad was about it.
就像不不不，没有理由开车，我是在手动挡车上学会开车的，我爸爸对此就是这么认真。
Oh you did same.
哦，你也是，一样。
Yeah in reverse.
是的，倒车。
I've learned to drive down our driveway in reverse was the first That's a high degree of difficulty.
我学会了倒车开出我们的车道，那是第一次，那难度很高。
Yeah, that's also a little bit.
是的，那也有点。
We're old.
我们老了。
That's old tech We're getting a little with us an old tech moment in our lives.
那是旧技术，我们生活中出现了一个旧技术的时刻。
Yeah, but yeah, my my parents my dad had a stick shift I think that wasn't that was not he was a car lover.
是的，但是的，我，我父母，我爸爸有一辆手动挡车，我想那不是，那不是，他是个爱车的人。
That was just he was cheap Yeah, he just had kept it a long time and he wasn't that great.
那只是因为他很抠门，是啊，他只是把它留了很久，而且他也不是那么好。
Yeah, you know what else was really funny in this episode Teenage Marshall with his brothers very funny with the head the chicken head the chicken head cocks thing They're like do they he does he does that thing?
是啊，你知道这一集中还有什么真的很有趣吗？青少年时期的马歇尔和他的兄弟们，非常有趣，那个鸡头，鸡头公鸡的东西，他们就像，他们，他做了那个动作？
And the perfectly placed zits and the braces.
还有位置完美的青春痘和牙套。
The mullet, the super hardcore mullet, spiky, like that was brilliant.
那个鲻鱼头，超级硬核的鲻鱼头，尖尖的，那真是太棒了。
That whole sequence is funny.
整个序列都很有趣。
Again, it's fun for you guys playing long-term characters to go back and kind of play a different version of those characters by the young versions.
再说一次，对于你们这些扮演长期角色的演员来说，回去扮演这些角色的不同版本，也就是年轻版本，是很有趣的。
And I can see how much fun you guys are having about those brothers, the seven foot tall brothers.
我能看出你们在扮演那些兄弟，那些七英尺高的兄弟时有多开心。
So I've got a weird story about this episode.
所以我关于这一集有一个奇怪的故事。
So I started noticing that certain things what happened on the show, that then in some sort of weird rhyming, almost, sometimes literal, but more like rhyming way would start to happen to me in life.
我开始注意到，剧集中发生的一些事情，然后以某种奇怪的押韵方式，几乎是，有时是字面上的，但更多的是像押韵一样，开始在我的生活中发生。
The summer, I think between, yeah, this summer, I think, between second and third season, my friend Bram, my best friend from high school, we decided to like go on a road trip and we drove to Sedona, Arizona.
那个夏天，我想在第二季和第三季之间，是的，那个夏天，我想，在第二季和第三季之间，我的朋友布拉姆，我高中最好的朋友，我们决定去公路旅行，我们开车去了亚利桑那州的塞多纳。
This is before GPS like phones and stuff, or write about it, but I didn't have it on my phone.
这是在GPS手机之类的东西出现之前，或者关于它，但我手机上没有。
But I remember MapQuest.
但我记得MapQuest。
I printed out the directions on MapQuest, but I must have done something wrong.
我打印出了MapQuest上的路线，但我一定做错了什么。
So we drive and we get stranded on a country road in Arizona and ran out of gas like we ran out of gas.
所以我们开车，被困在亚利桑那州的一条乡村公路上，汽油用完了，就像我们汽油用完了。
And we found a little like county gas station and we kind of, we, you know, on fumes, we just pulled in and we just had to like roll back the seats and close our eyes and go to sleep.
我们找到了一个小小的县级加油站，我们，你知道，在油箱见底的情况下，我们只是开了进去，我们不得不把座位放倒，闭上眼睛睡觉。
We didn't have to hold each other.
我们不必互相拥抱。
Until it opens the next day.
直到第二天开门。
Yeah.
是啊。
Until it opened the next day.
直到第二天开门。
And then it was like 7 a.m.
然后大概是早上7点。
at open.
开门了。
We figured out how to go.
我们弄清楚了怎么走。
And we finally got there.
我们终于到了那里。
But as we were, as it was happening, I was like, dude, this happened on how I made this.
但当它发生时，我就想，伙计，这在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里发生过。
This is an actual thing that happened to Dad and Marshall.
这是爸爸和马歇尔身上发生的真实事情。
And you just slept in the car.
你们真的睡在车里了？
Did you actually sleep?
你们真的睡着了吗？
At some point there's like, let's lean this back.
在某个时刻，就像，把这个放倒吧。
We probably got like a good 90 minutes, like a solid 90.
我们可能睡了大概90分钟，扎扎实实的90分钟。
But you know, it was alarming.
但你知道，这很令人担忧。
It was like, where are we?
就像，我们在哪？
I would totally be afraid.
我会完全害怕的。
Like just in the middle of that, isn't it?
就像在中间，不是吗？
I mean, it was fun.
我的意思是，这很有趣。
It was fun in the way that when you survived something like that, you look back on it and laugh, but in the moment, it was no fun.
当你从那样的事情中幸存下来时，回首往事并大笑起来，这很有趣，但在那一刻，一点也不好玩。
Terrifying.
太可怕了。
And also, like, really annoyed at myself, like, then I have the direction.
而且，就像，对自己真的很生气，就像，我没有路线。
And there's no solution.
而且没有解决办法。
We didn't have smartphones.
我们没有智能手机。
You just have your shitty map quest printout.
你只有你那烂透了的MapQuest打印件。
You're like, I guess this is wrong.
你就像，我想这是错的。
So what the fuck are we going to do here?
那我们到底该怎么办？
How do you feel so helpless?
你怎么会感到如此无助？
It was like the last moment where some, it was literally like the last moment on Earth, something like that could happen.
那就像是最后时刻，某种，这简直就像地球上最后时刻，可能会发生这样的事情。
Like a month later, you could have solved that problem.
就像一个月后，你就能解决那个问题了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Old's tech.
老式科技。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Well, I mean, did you guys bond more, or were you just annoyed by the experience?
我是说，你们之间的关系更亲密了，还是说你们只是对这段经历感到厌烦？
Oh, it's a great story.
哦，这是一个很棒的故事。
He didn't, he spoke at my wedding.
他没有，他在我的婚礼上致辞了。
I don't think he mentioned it in the wedding to us.
我不觉得他在婚礼上跟我们提过这件事。
But there he was at your wedding.
但他确实出现在了你的婚礼上。
That's the thing.
问题就在这儿。
That's what's great about this episode.
这就是这一集精彩的地方。
It's like, the Fierro is like this friendship forging device.
就好像，Fiero 就像是一个锻造友谊的装置。
You know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
Like they, we see two best friendships for him and we see Barney be vulnerable.
就像他们，我们看到了他与人建立的两段最深厚的友谊，也看到了巴尼脆弱的一面。
Barney's like, I can't drive.
巴尼说，我不会开车。
And he has this incredibly embarrassing experience with Ted.
而且他和泰德经历了那段极其尴尬的往事。
Everyone winds up closer to each other and knowing each other better.
每个人最终都变得更亲近，也更了解彼此了。
Like some kind of honesty or something comes out inside that Fierro, it's like this weird little laboratory for creating friendships.
就像某种诚实之类的东西在那辆 Fiero 里迸发出来，它就像是一个创造友谊的奇怪小实验室。
Another biggest laugh among the cast that I remember so strongly was Neil love it turning around to the wall.
我记得演员阵容中另一个让我印象深刻的爆笑点，是尼尔转过身面对墙壁。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Wipping his head around go, I hate it.
猛地转过头说，我讨厌它。
Having to restart himself to get the proper wind up to that was so funny.
为了达到那种恰到好处的蓄力效果，他不得不重新来过，那太搞笑了。
He, we had to do many takes of that.
他，我们那场戏拍了很多遍。
Like I don't know, it's similar to the Butterfucco pants.
就像，我不知道，这和“Butterfucco”裤子那段很像。
that also has the chicken headcock from Marshall.
那段还有马修像小鸡一样歪头的动作。
It's a, yeah.
那是，没错。
Like we really had to, it was, I just found it so strange and inventive.
我们真的必须，那太，我只是觉得它非常奇怪且富有创意。
And in the same way, like Barney, you know how we said the meta question is does Barney know he's in a sitcom?
同样地，就像巴尼，你知道我们之前说的那个元问题吗：巴尼知道自己身处情景喜剧中吗？
He does.
他知道。
He knows, he knows.
他知道，他知道。
He in some level knows.
他在某种程度上是知道的。
He is able to get away with like such heightened theatricality that none of the other characters really would be able to get away with.
他能够表现出那种极度夸张的戏剧性，而其他角色都无法做到这一点。
So true.
太对了。
And that was one.
那是一个例子。
I don't remember, was that written in the script, or was that just Neil?
我不记得了，那是剧本里写的，还是尼尔即兴发挥的？
No, that would have been written in the script.
不，那应该是剧本里写的。
I think that's a solid Chris Harris joke.
我觉得那是克里斯·哈里斯写的一个很棒的笑话。
I mean, Neil killed it and like hit it out of the park, but that's definitely, that's a Chris Harris.
我是说，尼尔演活了它，表现得非常出色，但那绝对是克里斯·哈里斯的手笔。
Chris Harris is good at like creating weird little rules of what's gonna happen.
克里斯·哈里斯很擅长创造一些奇怪的小规则，来决定接下来会发生什么。
Like that's self restart thing, that's very Chris Harris.
就像那个自我重启的动作，非常有克里斯·哈里斯的风格。
The Zitch Dog thing, that's also, I think Chris Harris' family might have invented Zitch Dog, or it's a twist on some other game that his family needs.
“Zitch Dog”那个梗，我也觉得可能是克里斯·哈里斯的家人发明的，或者是他家人玩的一种游戏的变体。
And people, I'm sure, play Zitch Dog.
而且我相信人们确实会玩“Zitch Dog”。
Oh, definitely.
哦，肯定的。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
wake up and it turns out they were right there in Exo Motel and that dude has his dog who thinks they're, she just chases them away and sees homophobic towards them.
醒来后发现他们就在汽车旅馆里，那个家伙带着他的狗，那只狗觉得他们是……她只是把他们赶走，而且对他们有同性恋恐惧症。
The fact that the dog is that he had another zetched dog that Marshall gets and Ted doesn't.
事实上，他还有另一只“Zitch Dog”，马修抓到了，而泰德没有。
That's like such a classic Chris Arristan.
那真是非常典型的克里斯·哈里斯风格。
Chris Arrist creates these like machines, these Rube Goldberg machines that are just like, these elaborate like puzzle boxes and just stuff just comes back and you don't know what's a setup.
克里斯·哈里斯创造了这些机器，这些鲁布·戈德堡机械，就像精心设计的解谜盒，东西会不断回旋，你根本不知道什么是铺垫。
Jokes are told in reverse.
笑话是倒着讲的。
You know, like he's, that's that, he's very good at that.
你知道，他非常擅长这个。
So yeah, he would have, he would have written that wind up then I think for Neil.
所以是的，我想那个蓄力动作肯定是他为尼尔写的。
Good Pulp Fiction Reference.
很好的《低俗小说》梗。
There's a Pulp Fiction Reference, soaking up the brains where- Oh my God, Harvey Keitel.
有个《低俗小说》的梗，清理脑浆的地方——哦天哪，哈维·凯特尔。
Harvey Keitel, you know, Robin is Keitel and that's he and that's so, you gotta soak that soup up.
哈维·凯特尔，你知道，罗宾就是凯特尔，那是他，所以你得把那汤汁清理干净。
She's the fixer.
她是那个“清理工”。
She goes into fixer mode.
她进入了“清理工”模式。
Yeah.
没错。
I liked, it kind of like the birthday countdown with Marshall's dad.
我喜欢这个，它有点像马修父亲的生日倒计时。
or the clock.
或者是那个时钟。
The odometer gives it a kind of framing.
里程表给它提供了一种框架感。
That's very cool.
那非常酷。
I love the odometer, yeah.
我喜欢里程表，是的。
It's great, because it gives you that feeling of years passing, history of us.
这很棒，因为它给了你一种岁月流逝、属于我们的历史感。
And we all know how long it takes to go from 100,000 to 200,000 miles.
我们都知道从 10 万英里到 20 万英里需要多长时间。
And that's the other thing I think this episode services, it's just the history, the shared, how far they've all come together as a group.
我认为这一集还承载了另一件事，那就是历史，那种共享的、他们作为一个团队共同走过了多远。
I really, I think this episode really captures them as a family.
我真的觉得这一集真正捕捉到了他们作为一家人的感觉。
Because how many, who do you put 200,000 miles a car with your family.
因为有多少人，你会和你的家人一起开着车跑 20 万英里。
Yeah.
是啊。
And it's also like, you know, sometimes cars are annoying status symbols.
而且，你知道，有时候车只是烦人的身份象征。
Like, I'm not a car person.
比如，我不是个爱车的人。
Like, I don't, I just want it to work.
我只是希望它能正常工作。
Yeah, Sam, but, but a car can also be like a house, like it can have, it can be a store house of enormous amounts of memories of road trips.
是的，山姆，但车也可以像房子一样，它可以是一个储存了大量公路旅行回忆的仓库。
And it's also like, there's something we live in a, you know, material realm where we got to get these annoying big bodies from place to place.
而且，我们生活在一个物质世界里，我们必须把这些烦人的大身体从一个地方带到另一个地方。
Yeah.
没错。
And a car is like, that's how we do it.
而车就是我们实现这一目标的方式。
You know, mostly, you know, that's how we do it.
你知道，大多数情况下，这就是我们的方式。
But you know, most people aren't going to get as attached to an airplane, but you, you really, um, there's something each stain on a car, especially the car, my sit, my dad had this 1984 Honda Civic hatchback.
但你知道，大多数人不会对飞机产生这种依恋，但你真的，车上的每一处污渍，尤其是那辆车，我爸爸曾有一辆 1984 年的本田思域掀背车。
This is the stick shift I learned to drive on with a cassette player.
那就是我学开手动挡时用的车，上面还有个卡带播放器。
Was it white?
是白色的吗？
Yeah, that's my dad.
是的，那是我爸爸的车。
That's the same car as my dad's.
和我爸爸的车一模一样。
It was silver.
它是银色的。
I was basically the same car.
基本上是同一款车。
But we all drove it to high school.
但我们都开着它去高中。
And I mean, eight to 10 blocks away.
我是说，离家只有八到十个街区远。
Right.
没错。
By the time my little sister Joanna was driving, I think I called the car Lucy.
到我妹妹乔安娜开车的时候，我想我把那辆车叫作“露西”。
But by the time Joanna was driving Lucy to school, and maybe even by the time I was, we were forbidden from taking it on the highway.
但当乔安娜开着露西去学校时，甚至可能在我开的时候，我们就被禁止开上高速公路了。
Like it was too unsafe.
因为它太不安全了。
It's too dangerous.
太危险了。
These rusted kind of, it looked like bullet holes on the side, like, it was literally just like the car you hold on to so your kids can can practice driving and go to school.
那些生锈的地方看起来像侧面的弹孔，它真的就是那种你留着给孩子们练习开车和去学校的车。
And that's same.
那是一样的。
I inherited the car that was just like not good enough for my dad to drive to New York City from Long Island anymore.
我继承的那辆车，对我爸爸来说已经不适合从长岛开到纽约市了。
And then I like figured I had to fit an entire drum set in this little shitty, Honda Civic when I was like going to play drums places.
然后我发现我得把整套鼓塞进这辆破旧的本田思域里，去别的地方打鼓。
But then when the car, I remember when we all, we kind of like bid farewell, I think, you know, I was in college.
但当那辆车，我记得当我们告别它时，我想，我在上大学。
Like, when Lucy went away, there was like a real heart.
当露西离开时，真的有一种心碎的感觉。
Why Lucy, by the way, why Lucy, what was the significance?
顺便问一下，为什么叫露西，有什么意义吗？
I have zero idea.
我完全不知道。
I feel like maybe it was like a female name, like a ship has a female name.
我觉得可能因为它是个女性名字，就像船通常有女性名字一样。
Yeah, you know, totally, totally, yeah.
是啊，完全同意，完全同意。
I think that's a BB King's guitar too, isn't it?
我想那也是BB King的吉他，对吧？
Lucille, it's a very close thing.
露西尔，非常接近了。
Lucille, yeah, yeah, yeah.
露西尔，没错，没错，没错。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
So, but a car can really hold a ton of memories.
所以，但一辆车确实能承载成吨的回忆。
Yeah.
是的。
that first car, that first one, you know.
那第一辆车，最初的那一辆，你知道的。
Yeah, it went from Marshall's brothers to him and then basically it became the vehicle of this little family.
是的，它从马歇尔的兄弟传给他，然后基本上就成了这个小家庭的交通工具。
I mean, literally there's a scene of Ted trying to teach Barney how to drive like he's Barney's dad or he's Barney's older brother.
我的意思是，确实有一个场景是泰德试图教巴尼开车，就像他是巴尼的爸爸或者哥哥一样。
It's so like there's something intimate about being in a car together.
这真的很像，一起在车里有一种亲密感。
Marshall and Ted almost die like Lily and Robin invent this lie that bonds them forever.
马歇尔和泰德差点死了，就像莉莉和罗宾编造了一个将她们永远联系在一起的谎言。
Like it's, it's great.
就像，这太棒了。
It is, it's this little, and it, go us for also making an episode so dynamic and interesting that's basically in a little metal box.
确实，这是一个小小的，而且，我们要感谢自己制作了一集如此动态和有趣的剧集，它基本上发生在一个小金属盒子里。
Most, you know, 60% of that episode is two people sending in a car.
大部分，你知道，那一集60%的时间是两个人坐在车里。
Right.
没错。
I'm impressed that the episode was so dynamic and kinetic and- Could you introduce- I should set out to 500 miles in the Proclaimers, by the way, for helping that, for helping that.
我很佩服那一集如此动态和充满活力——顺便说一下，你能介绍一下吗——我应该提到《Proclaimers》的《500 Miles》，因为那首歌帮了大忙。
Oh geez, we'll talk about that.
哦天哪，我们待会儿聊那个。
But had you introduced the Fierro that Marshall had a Fierro before?
但你之前介绍过马歇尔有辆Fiero吗？
Yeah, we had, we saw him drive it to Philadelphia in Sweet Tastes of Liberty.
是的，我们见过他在《自由的甜蜜滋味》里开着它去费城。
We've glimpsed it a few times, which I'm so happy about, because I hate on sitcoms where you have to invent, like, ah, this thing was, it's been so important.
我们瞥见过它几次，我对此很高兴，因为我讨厌情景喜剧里那种你必须凭空捏造的情况，比如“啊，这东西一直很重要”。
It's been with us all these years, and you've never seen it before on the show.
它陪伴了我们这么多年，但你在剧里却从未见过它。
It's total bullshit.
那简直是胡扯。
But we saw it just enough times for it to feel meaningful enough.
但我们展示它的次数恰到好处，让它感觉很有意义。
Again, it operates as like, oh, isn't this a silly funny episode about funny silly things that happened in a car?
再说一次，它就像是，哦，这不是一集关于车里发生的有趣傻事的搞笑剧集吗？
But it also much like most really great how I made your mother episodes, has this undercurrent of pathos and reality to it, which is time is passing.
但它也像大多数《老爸老妈浪漫史》的精彩剧集一样，有一种悲伤和现实的潜流，那就是时光流逝。
Yeah, and who am I now?
是的，现在的我是谁？
Who am I?
我是谁？
If I let go of this thing, who am I?
如果我放手这个东西，我是谁？
Loss is woven into a life.
失去是编织在生活里的。
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
And when you relinquish a kind of object or memento, much like stuff in a way, that was less the pillow from the girlfriend or whatever, but objects take on a kind of frequency or resonance when we have them for a while.
当你放弃某种物品或纪念品时，就像某种东西一样，虽然它不像女朋友留下的枕头之类的，但当我们拥有它们一段时间后，物体会带有一种频率或共鸣。
Yeah, it was good to begin this episode with that idea of like the little things we cling to, the guy with the tattoo and the woman with the like little, you know, the piercing, like there's those things you hold on and you think, well, this is me.
是的，以这种我们紧抓不放的小事作为开端很好，那个有纹身的男人，还有那个有小穿孔的女人，你知道，有些东西你紧紧抓住，觉得“嗯，这就是我”。
This grounds me as me.
这让我感到脚踏实地。
And when you let go of those things, whether it's letting go of a childhood home or a pet dyes or like, these are rights of passage.
当你放手这些东西时，无论是离开童年的家还是宠物去世，这些都是成长的仪式。
It's not as huge as like a person in your life dying, but it's like there's all these little funerals, right?
它不像你生命中重要的人去世那么巨大，但就像是有很多小小的葬礼，对吧？
There are those little memorializations that we have along the way.
我们一路上都有那些小小的纪念仪式。
And this is one of them.
而这就是其中之一。
This is, yeah, and it's attached to the object is a kind of like stand-in or representative for the person we were.
这是，是的，它附着在物体上，就像是我们曾经那个人的替身或代表。
And the person we no longer are.
以及我们不再是的那个人。
My older sister Melanie helped me move out of my house in L.A., which I sold this past summer.
我姐姐梅兰妮帮我搬出了我在洛杉矶的房子，我去年夏天把它卖了。
And I spent three days just sifting through a life.
我花了三天时间整理我的一生。
Like my whole life in L.A.
就像我在洛杉矶的整个人生。
And a lot of it was like how I met your mother's stuff.
其中很多都是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的东西。
You know, I saw every cast photo book that we made and all these different letters from people and photos and it really felt like, I saved the stuff that felt really like, no, I'm gonna want it.
你知道，我看到了我们制作的每一本剧组相册，还有各种人的信件和照片，我真的觉得，我留下了那些感觉真的很重要的东西，不，我会想留着它的。
I'm gonna wanna see this in 19 years.
我19年后会想看这些的。
But a lot of the stuff I just, I said goodbye to it and I kind of thanked it.
但很多东西我只是，我跟它们说了再见，我感谢了它们。
And then 1-800 got junk, took it away.
然后1-800-GOT-JUNK把它们拉走了。
Shout out by the way to 1-800-000.
顺便给1-800-GOT-JUNK打个广告。
Today's episode is brought to you by one incredible company.
今天的节目由一家不可思议的公司赞助。
They came twice and they just haul it all away.
他们来了两次，把所有东西都拉走了。
No questions asked, it's unbelievable.
不问任何问题，简直不可思议。
But there's a kind of paradox which is that things and stuff, they hold this charge of memory, but there's also a weight to them.
但这里有一个悖论，那就是东西和物品，它们承载着记忆的电荷，但它们也有重量。
They hold us down.
它们拖累着我们。
I mean, everyone, when you do a purge of your house or your apartment, you can feel lighter, like something in you internally gets emptied out and rearranged.
我的意思是，每个人在清理房子或公寓时，都会感到更轻松，就像你内在的某些东西被清空并重新排列了。
Yes, it's like it's shedding a skin a little bit.
是的，就像蜕了一层皮一样。
If there's something like to move forward, you have to let go with some of that stuff.
如果有什么东西要向前看，你必须放下其中的一些东西。
And it's painful.
这很痛苦。
I mean, I held onto that house in LA after for like several years after how much mother.
我的意思是，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》结束后，我在洛杉矶的那栋房子里又住了好几年。
I moved back to New York and held on this house and rented it to a friend.
我搬回了纽约，但留着那栋房子，把它租给了一个朋友。
It was just like reluctance to let it go.
那只是因为不舍得放手。
And so because it was so many, that was my how I met your mother house.
因为那有太多回忆，那是我的《老爸老妈浪漫史》之屋。
That was where I made, that was where I lived for most of the series, that the show bought me that house, just a modest little house in Culver City, by the way.
那是我拍摄大部分剧集时住的地方，剧组给我买了那栋房子，顺便说一下，只是卡尔弗城一栋朴素的小房子。
It was nothing fancy.
它没什么特别的。
It was like, I bought it in season two.
就像，我在第二季买的它。
But, oh man, letting go of that house was painful.
但是，天哪，放弃那栋房子很痛苦。
But then once I did, it's like, now I really lived back in New York.
但一旦我做了，就像是，现在我才真正回到了纽约生活。
Something about holding on to it didn't quite seem like I fully had made the move or something.
保留着它似乎意味着我还没有完全搬走，或者类似的感觉。
Even though I did, I lived here.
尽管我确实搬了，我住在这里。
My kid was in school here, something about it.
我的孩子在这里上学，有些事情就是这样。
It's an interesting thing.
这是一件有趣的事情。
And it's also like, you can't take it with you.
而且就像是，你带不走它们。
Like, it's all going away eventually.
最终一切都会消失。
Yes, you cannot take it with you.
是的，你带不走它们。
You get the memories and that's the gift.
你得到了回忆，那才是礼物。
That is the gift.
那才是礼物。
We had a hilarious woman come over.
我们请了一位非常风趣的女士过来。
We hired a woman to help us before our son was born to help us, we have a big, like a big ish for New York storage closet and we needed help.
在我们儿子出生前，我们雇了一位女士来帮忙，我们在纽约有一个很大的储藏室，我们需要帮助。
Like what do we keep, what do we, and she just went through and she was merciless but in the funniest way, you know?
比如我们留什么，我们扔什么，她检查了一遍，她非常无情，但以最有趣的方式，你知道吗？
And a lot of the things she was like, we were like, we can't get rid of that.
很多东西她都说要扔，我们说，我们不能扔掉那个。
card from 2021 or whatever she'd like, take a picture of it, put a file, get a file of these are things that mean something to you on your phone, take a picture of it, throw out the actual thing.
2021年的卡片之类的，她会说，拍张照，存个档，在手机里建个文件夹，存下这些对你有意义的东西，然后把实物扔掉。
And yeah, she was so bad at that.
是的，她在这方面太厉害了。
I got to get better at that.
我得在这方面做得更好。
I sort of created a middle ground version where I've taken pictures of things and now I'm making a photo album of it.
我创造了一个中间地带，我给东西拍了照，现在正在制作相册。
So it's still physical in some way, but I just know that I'm going to look at that photo album a lot more than I'm going to go into my garage and open to a junk closet.
所以它在某种程度上仍然是实体的，但我知道我会比去车库打开杂物间看那些东西更常看那本相册。
Yeah, that's the thing.
是的，就是这样。
The stuff becomes inaccessible anyway.
反正东西放在那也无法触及。
I mean, I'll stack on a closet.
我的意思是，我会堆在壁橱里。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全正确。
There's also that feeling lighter.
还有那种变轻松的感觉。
The difference of getting rid of something literal, physical, when it's gone, it's so gone.
摆脱实实在在的物理东西的区别在于，当它消失时，它就真的消失了。
There's a lot of decisions you sort of make in your head where you could kind of go back one day and you could rethink something.
你在脑海中做出的很多决定，你总觉得有一天可以回去重新考虑。
But once you've thrown the thing out and that lighter feeling is, I move a lot.
但一旦你把东西扔掉，那种轻松的感觉，我经常搬家。
so I purge a lot.
所以我经常清理。
Brian underscored Nar, by the way, points to all of this.
顺便说一下，布莱恩强调了这一点，他指出了所有这些。
He says, I love how they talk about the Fierro like it was an old friend.
他说，我喜欢他们谈论Fiero的方式，就像它是一个老朋友。
It gives the feeling that the car was a character on the show.
这让人感觉这辆车是剧中的一个角色。
Throughout the entire series, Craig Carter, the writers and the actors themselves really made us viewers feel the nostalgia and memories each of the gang expressed so vividly.
在整个系列中，克雷格·卡特、编剧和演员们确实让我们观众感受到了主角团表达的怀旧和回忆，如此生动。
It tends to make me think of my own life and experiences, which is an indescribable feeling to get from a TV show.
这让我思考我自己的生活和经历，这是一种从电视剧中获得的难以言表的感受。
It's one of my favorite things about him.
这是我最喜欢他的地方之一。
That's nice.
那很好。
I mean, this isn't many of you.
我的意思是，你们中没多少人是这样的。
That's what this episode is.
这集讲的就是这个。
It's Marshall growing up, right?
这是马修的成长，对吧？
We're getting married.
我们要结婚了。
I'm going to have to get a different kind of job and drive it off kind of car.
我得换一份不同的工作，开一辆不同的车。
I'm going to be somewhat of a different person.
我将成为一个有点不同的人。
And it's like the letting go of that and the acceptance of change.
这就像是放下过去，接受改变。
And there is something kind of deep at the end of this episode.
这一集的结尾有一些深刻的东西。
And also, it is a character like if him was a Western, they'd be bidding farewell to a horse.
而且，这个角色就像是如果他在一部西部片里，他会向一匹马告别。
Or a stage coach or something, you know, like, it's, it's a, the car is a, is a very kind of American thing, you know, that, that you can get really attached to, to the, Yeah.
或者是一辆驿站马车之类的，你知道，汽车是一种非常美国化的东西，你知道，你会对它产生深厚的感情，是的。
Marshall's from Minnesota and like, you know, just like it, it's, it's his roots.
马修来自明尼苏达州，你知道，这就像是他的根。
It's his roots.
这是他的根。
And he drives to Connecticut.
他开车去康涅狄格州。
He drives to Connecticut from Minnesota and yeah, then Ted's from Ohio and like they're, they're outsiders.
他从明尼苏达开车去康涅狄格州，是的，泰德来自俄亥俄州，他们都是局外人。
That fear all got them to and from Wesleyan all those years.
那辆车这些年来一直载着他们往返于卫斯理大学。
And he met Lily with driving that car, you know, and this old man.
而且他是在开那辆车的时候遇见莉莉的，你知道，还有这个老伙计。
He musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
他一定是在爱上你的时候，爱上了纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
Because my wife is on a bit of a maternity leave from her, I don't know if she'll come back as our resident clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother.
因为我妻子正在休产假，我不知道她是否会以我们常驻临床心理学家的身份回归，她从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
But she did tell me a thing that sparked something, and I think I might have mentioned this before.
但她确实告诉我一件事，引发了一些思考，我想我之前可能提到过。
But she told me there's a studied psychological phenomenon that is if you start a relationship with someone in a slightly adversarial, like you're suspicious of them, have we talked about this?
但她告诉我有一个经过研究的心理学现象，就是如果你和某人开始一段关系时带有一点对抗性，比如你对他们持怀疑态度，我们谈过这个吗？
No.
没有。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
If you're suspicious of them or you have some crossed wires with a person, but then you you eventually become friends with them, you actually feel more fondness to them.
如果你对他们持怀疑态度，或者你们之间有些误会，但后来你最终和他们成为了朋友，你实际上会对他们产生更多的好感。
That's interesting.
这很有趣。
Because there was an initially a kind of hostility or suspicion.
因为最初有一种敌意或怀疑。
And I think it's funny that Ted and Marshall did not start out day one being good friends.
我觉得泰德和马修第一天并没有成为好朋友，这很有趣。
Yeah, it was not love at first sight.
是的，那不是一见钟情。
It was not love at first sight.
那不是一见钟情。
Distant roommates and this is what this is the Thanksgiving break that they're driving back for.
疏远的室友，这就是他们感恩节假期开车回去的原因。
That's why it's still snowing.
这就是为什么还在下雪。
Yeah.
是的。
So they had a couple months of like chili, like I guess we're going to be friends with different people, but we live in the same room.
所以他们有几个月的时间，就像是，好吧，我想我们会和不同的人做朋友，但我们住在同一个房间里。
Yeah.
是的。
And then it goes so deep so much deeper because of starting off ever so that's really interesting.
然后它变得如此深刻，因为从那种状态开始，这真的很有趣。
Well, yeah, then we did something psychologically accurate.
嗯，是的，然后我们做了一些心理学上准确的事情。
Yeah, I also when when Ted when he gets his spectacles knocked off, I always love saying my spectacles.
是的，还有当泰德的眼镜被打掉时，我总是喜欢说“我的眼镜”。
Sorry about your spectacles.
抱歉弄坏了你的眼镜。
He said is okay, they were decorative and my my lovely wife said right next to me.
他说没关系，它们是装饰性的，我可爱的妻子坐在我旁边说。
What a dork.
真是个书呆子。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh my God.
天哪。
And just like the fact that Marshall calls them spec calls them spectacles was a gifted of itself because you can tell Marshall Marshall probably did not enjoy having to call them spectacles but Ted clearly like these are my spectacles.
马修称它们为“眼镜”这一事实本身就是一个天赋，因为你可以看出马修可能并不喜欢称它们为眼镜，但泰德显然觉得“这是我的眼镜”。
My spectacles.
我的眼镜。
Yeah.
是的。
Josh, I'm listening the audio book of that.
乔什，我正在听那本有声书。
John and Paul a lot of story at The Beatles book.
关于约翰和保罗的《披头士》故事书。
You know, it's so good.
你知道，它太棒了。
They're friendship and they're it's so good.
他们的友谊，太棒了。
I'm obsessed with it.
我沉迷其中。
Josh recommended it.
乔什推荐的。
And I'm pretty sure that those like classic John Lennon and spectacles that he wore.
我很确定那些经典的约翰·列侬戴的眼镜。
I think there was a detail in that book that those were also decorative.
我想书里有一个细节说那些也是装饰性的。
I think he did have bad vision and did have prescription glasses, but I think he started wearing those empty, like without anything in that man.
我想他确实视力不好，也有处方眼镜，但我认为他开始戴那些空镜框，里面什么都没有。
It was like Ted's doing the exact same thing as John Lennon.
就像泰德在做和约翰·列侬完全一样的事情。
Well, it was also like you could see that Ted was still trying on costumes of Persona.
嗯，这也像是你能看出泰德还在尝试各种角色扮演。
Yes, he was just trying stuff.
是的，他只是在尝试各种东西。
See what works.
看看什么管用。
He was trying stuff on, you know.
他在尝试各种东西，你知道。
He was trying stuff on, oh my God.
他在尝试各种东西，天哪。
One thing, speaking of wives, my wife watched with me last night and when Marshall is like, they're all shitting on the making of origami cranes.
说到妻子，我妻子昨晚和我一起看，当马修说他们都在嘲笑折纸鹤的制作时。
My wife is like, what the fuck, man?
我妻子说，搞什么鬼，伙计？
Because we really did that at our wedding, and my wife folded a thousand in one origami cranes.
因为我们在婚礼上真的做了那个，我妻子折了一千零一只纸鹤。
And it was beautiful, and I loved it.
它很美，我很喜欢。
I can't do it to save my life.
我这辈子都做不到。
But she enlisted friends.
但她找了朋友帮忙。
It was like this gorgeous thing.
那是一件非常华丽的事情。
Their cranes made for life.
他们的鹤是为生活而折的。
They were like, and it was gorgeous all over all the tables.
它们在所有的桌子上，非常华丽。
And it was this whole thing, like everything about it was great.
这是一整件事，关于它的一切都很棒。
I loved it.
我很喜欢。
I didn't hate it all.
我一点也不讨厌它。
I had forgotten that at the beginning of this episode, right at the beginning of this episode, they shit all over that.
我忘了在这一集的开头，就在这一集的开头，他们把那个嘲笑了一通。
And Rebecca looked at me like, what the fuck, man?
丽贝卡看着我，就像在说，搞什么鬼，伙计？
Like, why are you gonna shit on my origami cream?
为什么你要嘲笑我的折纸鹤？
Rebecca, call me.
丽贝卡，给我打电话。
We'll start a support group for things that are nice about your personal life and how I met your mother writers.
我们将为那些在你的个人生活中很美好，却被《老爸老妈浪漫史》编剧嘲笑的事情建立一个支持小组。
Ridicule them.
嘲笑它们。
I'm wondering if she's down the hall hearing them.
我想知道她是否在走廊里听到了。
You say this right now, actually.
你现在说这个，其实。
Maybe she'll run in.
也许她会跑进来。
I know.
我知道。
We could be real dicks for some reason and every now and again.
我们有时会莫名其妙地变得很混蛋。
For no reason.
毫无理由。
Really for no reason.
真的毫无理由。
Sorry about that.
对此感到抱歉。
There is an unfortunate word.
这是一个不幸的词。
We just wanted to me a kalpa at the beginning of this episode.
我们只是想在这一集开头表达歉意。
I forgot about speaking of things that I didn't like at the beginning.
我忘了说到开头我不喜欢的事情。
Not good.
不好。
Lillie said something, said a word that has appeared a few times that is not beloved in 2025 by the trans community, and we apologize for that.
莉莉说了一个词，这个词出现过几次，在2025年并不受跨性别群体的喜爱，我们对此表示歉意。
We've talked about that in other episodes, and I'm always surprised and really bummed out that past selves thought that was okay.
我们在其他剧集中谈过这个问题，我总是很惊讶，也很难过，过去的自己竟然觉得那样没问题。
Alec, Alec, do you remember the episode where Craig and I, at the beginning, the episode went pretty deep on words and the meaning of them and why we try to do this?
亚历克，亚历克，你还记得克雷格和我开头的那一集吗，那一集深入探讨了词汇及其含义，以及我们为什么要尝试这样做？
Do you remember what episode that was?
你还记得那是哪一集吗？
I do not.
我不记得了。
We'll put it in the notes.
我们会把它放在笔记里。
We'll put it in the notes because it was, I thought as a, just as an exploration of two people in this world who were trying to tell stories and trying to, you know, update themselves and I thought it was really good.
我们会把它放在笔记里，因为我认为，作为一个在这个世界上试图讲故事，并试图更新自己的人，我觉得这真的很好。
I thought it was really good.
我觉得这真的很好。
Yeah.
是的。
是啊。
Yeah.
We want to own those things when we noticed them.
我们想在注意到这些东西的时候承认它们。
I'm glad you said that about this one too.
很高兴你也提到了这一点。
And it always goes by and it's always, it's always like the episode would have been better and the episode would have been better with that.
它总是转瞬即逝，而且总是让人觉得，如果那一集能有那个东西会更好。
Like these little things that just go by and you go, ah, I wish that wasn't in there.
就像这些小细节一闪而过，你会想，啊，真希望那段没放进去。
Well, it's kind of the onus you feel like okay every 20 seconds got to get a joke You know that that kind of burden you stumble on to a bad one once in a while and it doesn't age great So we do apologize about that.
嗯，这就像是一种负担，你会觉得每20秒就得抛出一个梗，你知道那种压力，偶尔会冒出一个烂梗，而且经不起时间的考验，所以我们对此表示歉意。
I did wonder if my plaid shirt was a Ohio State Buckeye reference because it's very scarlet and gray That would be great that would have been a great like inside reference bias or wardrobe folks.
我确实在想，我的格子衬衫是不是在致敬俄亥俄州立大学的七叶树队，因为它是深红灰配色的。那会很棒，那会是一个很棒的内部梗，或者说是服装组的偏好。
I wonder I wonder if that's true Yeah, who knows?
我不知道，我不知道那是不是真的，谁知道呢？
Yeah, I don't know.
是啊，我不知道。
Um, it was totally mutual made me laugh the um There's something 500 miles associated with how I made a mother has long outlived this.
嗯，这完全是相互的，让我笑了，那个……关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》中500英里的梗，它的生命力远超这一集。
It's outgrown this episode, like it's become a real thing.
它已经超越了这一集，变成了一个真实存在的梗。
And we see that it became a runner through the whole series when they go on road trips we'd hear and we'd hear it comes back and flashbacks and stuff.
我们看到它成了贯穿全剧的常驻梗，当他们去公路旅行时，我们能听到它，在闪回片段里它也会出现。
When it was funny, there's this movie that's coming out long enough from now that I did some rewrites on for a while.
说到好笑的事，有一部电影离现在还有一段时间才会上映，我之前参与过一些重写工作。
It's called the Sheep Detectives, Hugh Jackman's in it.
片名叫《羊群侦探》，休·杰克曼主演。
It's got a great cast.
演员阵容很强大。
It's a really cool movie.
那是一部很酷的电影。
I got to write on it a little bit.
我有幸写了一点。
I'm not the main writer by any means, but I got to do some work on it.
我绝不是主编剧，但我确实参与了一些工作。
And one thing I did was I wrote in that song into that movie, weirdly enough.
其中一件事就是，说来奇怪，我把那首歌写进了电影里。
And at one point, it was very featured in the movie in that it shrunk down.
有一段时间，它在电影里非常突出，后来被删减了。
It's only lightly featured in the movie, but the trailer just dropped for it yesterday.
它在电影里只是轻微地出现，但预告片昨天刚发布。
And it's that song because I wrote that song into that movie.
里面用的就是那首歌，因为我把它写进了电影。
And I just want to say I don't think anyone in the world has made the Proclaimers more royalty money than me, which is the strangest and lamest brag of all time, but it might be true.
我只想说，我不认为世界上有谁比我给“宣示者”乐队（The Proclaimers）贡献了更多的版税，这是史上最奇怪也最蹩脚的吹嘘，但可能是真的。
So yeah, you're welcome.
所以，不客气。
It's not lame to the Proclaimers.
对“宣示者”乐队来说这可不蹩脚。
You're welcome, Proclaimers, Scottish to Scottish twin brothers.
不客气，“宣示者”乐队，苏格兰双胞胎兄弟。
Where did, so I remember in the limo episode, you guys had a fight to the death over whether it was going to be, you give love a bad name, or what was the other needle straw that you were considering?
那么，我记得在加长轿车那一集，你们为了到底是选《You Give Love a Bad Name》还是另一首备选歌曲争得你死我活？
And anyway, you want it by journey.
总之，你们选了Journey乐队的《Any Way You Want It》。
Journey.
Journey乐队。
So Lorde was really just going, he was going down with that ship and we, yes, it almost came to blows.
所以寇碧当时真的坚持要用那首歌，我们，是的，差点打起来。
So, was there any, how did you land on 500 miles as this one stuck cassette?
那么，你们是怎么决定用《500 Miles》作为那张卡在播放器里的磁带的？
I think, I mean, it was this, there was no argument.
我想，我的意思是，这根本没有争议。
Once we hit upon it, it was just, it was the perfect song and it was just like, what song just big, the way it begins and that chorus is over and over and over and that idea of the song that goes away and comes back again where you can hate it, but then you can hear it again a long way later and love it all over again.
一旦我们想到它，它就是完美的歌曲，就像是，这首歌的开头，还有那个一遍又一遍重复的副歌，以及那种歌曲消失又回来，你可以讨厌它，但很久之后再听到又会重新爱上它的感觉。
It just, it just was the perfect song.
它就是完美的歌曲。
And again, another great Chris Harris joke setups and payoffs that little moment where they're, they think they're dying in the freezing cold in the pitch black.
再说一次，克里斯·哈里斯又一个很棒的笑点铺垫和收尾，就是他们以为自己在严寒和漆黑中快要冻死的那一刻。
And they say, let's just turn on the heat for one second.
他们说，让我们把暖气打开一秒钟。
And it comes down so fucking loud for like three seconds is that that made me laugh all that.
然后音乐响得震耳欲聋，持续了三秒钟，这让我笑个不停。
That's, that's a great Chris Harris joke there, which is you've forgotten about it just the right amount of time that when it comes back.
那是克里斯·哈里斯很棒的笑点，你已经把它忘得差不多了，当它再次出现时……
that it's that Marshall calls it a cassingle.
马歇尔管它叫“磁带单曲”（cassingle）。
A cassingle?
磁带单曲？
Yes, yes, big laughs in my house on the word cassingle.
是的，是的，我家里人听到“磁带单曲”这个词时笑得很大声。
And now again, you have to explain that.
现在你又得解释这个词了。
We should really spend more time explaining stuff to the people in their 20s.
我们真的应该花更多时间给20多岁的人解释这些东西。
The idea that just a single one song and a cassette was sometimes in the 80s called a cassingle.
那种只有一首歌的磁带在80年代有时被称为“磁带单曲”。
When you read Shakespeare, you see that.
当你读莎士比亚时，你会看到这种情况。
Like you have to look in the glossary of like, what does this mean?
你得去查词汇表，看看这是什么意思。
Because there was so much slang, there was so much.
因为当时有太多的俚语，太多的东西。
And Elizabethan audiences understood everything.
而伊丽莎白时代的观众什么都懂。
Like you didn't, they understood it all.
他们全都听得懂。
It was mass entertainment.
那是大众娱乐。
Yeah, it was all like topical references.
是的，全都是时事梗。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Yeah, cuz single, I think there's people listening to this podcast that don't know what a cassette is, much less a cuz single.
因为“磁带单曲”，我觉得听这个播客的人里有人根本不知道什么是磁带，更别提“磁带单曲”了。
Again, the poor English is a second language people who are trying to learn.
再次为那些试图学习英语的非母语人士感到抱歉。
You're like, let's just tell you now, you're not gonna need cuz single.
你会想，现在就告诉你们吧，你们以后用不到“磁带单曲”这个词。
No, no, you don't need it, but it's nice to have it in your bag's pocket.
不，不，你不需要它，但把它装在口袋里也不错。
It's nice to have it.
有它挺好的。
You will only be fun for other, how I met my mother.
这只会对其他《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝有趣。
Oh, may you rust in peace is a great pun.
哦，“愿你安息”（rust in peace）是个很棒的双关语。
It's a good, it's a solid dad joke.
这是一个很好的、扎实的冷笑话。
It's a solid pun.
这是一个扎实的双关语。
Okay, so one of the biggest laughs is a tiny little throwaway.
好了，最大的笑点之一是一个微小的随口一说。
Who says like, I'm sure Robins had some disappointment and COVID.
谁说了句，我肯定罗宾经历过一些失望和COVID（新冠）。
Where she just looks, yeah, she shakes it up like me.
她只是看着，是的，她摇了摇头，像我一样。
That's just COVID coming up with that.
那是寇碧自己想出来的。
I don't think that's in the script.
我不认为剧本里有这个。
I think that's just, I think so.
我想应该是吧。
I think that's just COVID be like, no, fuck.
我想那只是寇碧在说，不，该死。
I've been also in the whole time.
我一直都在这里。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么呢？
It was one of my favorites.
这是我最喜欢的片段之一。
It's almost like she becomes Barney in that moment.
那一刻她简直变成了巴尼。
Yes, and which is great.
是的，这很棒。
And plants that seed of the two of them having connection.
并且埋下了两人产生联系的种子。
I don't think we scripted that.
我不认为是我们写进剧本的。
I would almost guarantee that was just Kobe finding that.
我几乎可以保证那是寇碧自己发现的。
The guy who played the mechanic was really great.
演修理工的那个人真的很棒。
He seemed like a mechanic.
他看起来就像个修理工。
He was really, and he was a nice guy.
他真的很棒，而且是个好人。
Like he was just nice on set.
他在片场人很好。
We like talking to him.
我们喜欢和他聊天。
And on the final day of filming, I guess it was a Friday, we wrapped, I think we filmed that last on a Friday.
在拍摄的最后一天，我想是个周五，我们杀青了，我想我们最后拍的是那一幕。
But we say goodbye to him.
我们和他道别。
We're all standing there.
我们都站在那里。
Or maybe it was me, Kobe and Jason.
或者可能只有我和寇碧还有杰森。
I think it was just the three of us.
我想只有我们三个。
And the guy says, all right, goodbye.
那个人说，好了，再见。
And he starts walking away.
然后他开始走开。
And he's like halfway down the stage.
他走到舞台中间。
And for some reason, Jason goes, hey, hey.
不知为什么，杰森喊道，嘿，嘿。
And the guy turns around.
那个人转过身来。
Jason goes, you have a really nice way about you.
杰森说，你这人真不错。
And the guy looks at you.
那个人看着你。
Thanks, thanks, man, for years.
谢谢，谢谢你，伙计，多年来。
Jason and I have been saying this to each other.
杰森和我一直在对彼此说这句话。
It's just like, he's like, why did I save it?
就像是，他会说，我为什么要说那个？
What, what came over me that I needed?
我当时是怎么了，为什么非要说那句？
We'd already had like a nice goodbye.
我们明明已经好好道过别了。
But he was just say, hey, you have a really nice way about you.
但他只是说，嘿，你这人真不错。
Like it was like an old timey Coke commercial or something, like the football player.
就像那种老式的可乐广告一样，比如那个橄榄球运动员。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Don't you just ask something to the kid or the kid says something to the football player?
难道不是你问孩子什么，或者孩子对橄榄球运动员说了什么吗？
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
It was like field of dreams, like moonlight Graham.
就像《梦幻之地》里的月光格雷厄姆。
Hey, you were good.
嘿，你表现得不错。
Hey, you were good kid.
嘿，你表现得不错，孩子。
You were good kid.
你表现得不错，孩子。
You have a really nice way about you.
你这人真不错。
So the guy just looks back, is confusing, probably keeps walking and that's just it.
所以那个人只是回头看了一眼，感到困惑，可能继续走开了，就这样。
And Siegel's like, why did I, what happened there?
然后西格尔就想，我为什么，那里发生了什么？
Why did I say that?
我为什么要那样说？
Like what came over me?
就像我怎么了？
But also like here in Jason's defense, the guy had a nice way about it.
但话说回来，为杰森辩护一下，那个人确实挺不错的。
Craig said, text Jason, hey, you have a really nice way about you.
克雷格说，给杰森发短信，嘿，你这人真不错。
With no context.
没有任何上下文。
Just see if you're 19 years later.
看看你是不是19年后还能记得。
Do I put it in quotes or no?
我要加引号吗，还是不用？
No, just say it, just say it.
不用，直接说，直接说就行。
He would have it.
他会明白的。
I promise you, he will know.
我向你保证，他会知道的。
We'll see if he gets back to us.
我们看看他会不会回复我们。
Okay.
好的。
It needs to be, You have a really nice way about that.
必须是，“你这人真不错”。
It needs to be, the responsible needs to clearly show that he remembers it or else I'm gonna be saying it.
必须是，回复必须清楚地表明他记得这件事，否则我就要说出来了。
I hope, I hope he remembers what I'm talking about.
我希望，我希望他记得我在说什么。
We talked about it and not, like we were talking about it in season nine.
我们谈论过它，不是那种，就像我们在第九季谈论它一样。
Like it was a runner.
就像它是一个贯穿全剧的梗。
I've never heard the story before, I love it so much.
我以前从没听过这个故事，我太喜欢了。
It was a runner that was enough that stuck around long enough that I think he'll know what I'm talking about.
这是一个贯穿全剧的梗，存在的时间足够长，我想他会知道我在说什么。
You know, we were up in the writer's room so much.
你知道，我们在编剧室待了那么久。
There were things happening down on set that we didn't know about.
片场发生了一些我们不知道的事情。
And this makes me happy and sad at the same time, sad that I miss it at the time.
这让我既高兴又难过，难过的是我当时错过了。
And I'm glad to know it now.
但我很高兴现在知道了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Hey, you have really, really.
嘿，你真的，真的。
I swear about you.
我发誓。
I've got, you know, our fans have very nice ways about them.
你知道，我们的粉丝人也都很好。
And I've got two sort of simple questions before we get on to two Fierro inspired letters.
在进入两封受菲耶罗启发的信件之前，我有两个简单的问题。
You know, I know the breaks in logic are not, you know, are to be understood when it happens.
你知道，我知道逻辑上的漏洞，你知道，当它发生时是可以理解的。
It happens many people wonder when Barney learned to drive because it says it, Emily Brown on Facebook says, in this episode, Barney doesn't know what to drive, which gives us a hilarious scene.
很多人想知道巴尼是什么时候学会开车的，因为脸书上的艾米丽·布朗说，在这一集中，巴尼不知道怎么开车，这给我们带来了一个搞笑的场景。
In an episode, in a later season, Barney's storyline is that he's trying to get out of speeding tickets and he keeps getting pulled over.
在后来的一集中，巴尼的剧情是他试图逃避超速罚单，结果一直被拦下。
When did Barney learn to drive?
巴尼到底是什么时候学会开车的？
Did you guys realize after that future episode that he previously hadn't known how to drive?
你们有没有意识到在未来的那一集之后，他之前是不会开车的？
Oh boy, I can definitely picture us having screwed up the mass on that.
天哪，我绝对能想象到我们在那方面搞砸了。
Although I don't, we didn't say exactly what year that was, that flashback of him in Ted learning, I don't think.
虽然我不，我不认为我们确切地说过那是哪一年，那个他向泰德学习的闪回。
Also our default, our default defense is unreliable narrator, older kid.
还有我们的默认，我们的默认辩护是不可靠的叙述者，老年的泰德。
Unreliable narrator.
不可靠的叙述者。
Who remembers dates all the time?
谁能一直记得日期呢？
I mean, where I thought you were going with this is another critique I've heard of this episode, just logic wise people love the episode, but like there's other times Marshall allows food and drink in the Fierro in the series, I think.
我是说，我以为你要说的是我听到的关于这一集的另一个批评，只是逻辑上人们喜欢这一集，但比如马歇尔在系列剧中还有其他时候允许在菲耶罗里吃喝，我想。
I think that's been pointed out before, and I'm pretty sure that that's right, and we did fuck that one up.
我想之前有人指出过这一点，我很确定那是对的，我们确实搞砸了那一点。
Because I think you see other flashbacks where they're talking about eating beef jerky and drinking tantrum on a road trip, and it's like clearly that rule was not in effect at that point.
因为我想你看到了其他的闪回，他们谈论在公路旅行中吃牛肉干和喝Tantrum饮料，显然那个规则在当时并没有生效。
But it's a lot, you know, it's hard to keep the logic of like a two-hour movie in your head.
但这很多，你知道，很难在脑子里保持一部两小时电影的逻辑。
You guys were keeping nine years, like there's going to be, and I think in some ways that's part of the shaggy charm of a long-running show.
你们保持了九年，就像会有，而且我认为在某些方面，这就是长寿剧那种粗糙魅力的一部分。
Yeah.
是啊。
And boy, you're right, the unreliable narrator piece.
天哪，你说得对，不可靠的叙述者那部分。
Well, let's just keep going about it and get it a jail-free card.
好吧，让我们继续讨论下去，给它一张免罪卡。
On Instagram, Mark Brittner has a musical question.
在Instagram上，马克·布里特纳有一个关于音乐的问题。
How did you get the triumphant instrumental version of, I'm going to be 500 miles?
你们是怎么得到《I'm Gonna Be (500 Miles)》那首凯旋般的器乐版本的？
Did you hire an orchestra or was it made with ten?
你们雇了一个管弦乐队还是用合成器制作的？
Now, our brilliant composer, John Swahart, who Alec, we should have on some episode.
我们的天才作曲家约翰·斯瓦哈特，亚历克，我们应该请他上节目。
Maybe, I mean, I don't, maybe we can choose one that had a really featured, good, like original song that we did but he and his and Brian Kim who worked with him as a co-composer and a junior composer then did more and more as series one too.
也许吧，我是说，我不，也许我们可以选一集，里面有非常突出、好的原创歌曲，我们做过，但他和布莱恩·金（当时作为联合作曲家和初级作曲家与他合作，后来在第一季到第二季做得越来越多）。
We would just say to them orchestral 500 miles by the Proclaimers and be like yep I got you and they would come back in and they did you know it's not a real orchestra.
我们只会对他们说，管弦乐版的《500 Miles》，由Proclaimers演唱，他们会说好的，我明白了，然后他们会回来，你知道，那不是真正的管弦乐队。
Although when we did the 100th episode suits musical that was a real orchestra.
虽然我们在做第100集《西装》音乐剧时，那是真正的管弦乐队。
That was amazing.
那太棒了。
We'll get there.
我们会聊到那里的。
You know I'm just remembering Remember when I used to do a song of the day on Twitter, Craig, for years, so the day of the finale airing that morning, my song of the day was by my friend Ryan O'Neill, who records as Sleeping at Last.
你知道我正在回忆，还记得我以前在推特上做每日一歌吗，克雷格，做了好几年，所以大结局播出的那天早上，我的每日一歌是我朋友瑞安·奥尼尔唱的，他以“Sleeping at Last”的名义录音。
Did you guys ever use a Sleeping at Last tune on the show?
你们在剧里用过“Sleeping at Last”的曲子吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
But he's amazing and he's got this huge career I saw him at Carnegie Hall, I think, last year, year before.
但他很棒，他有非常辉煌的职业生涯，我想去年或前年我在卡内基音乐厅见过他。
But he did this achingly sad and beautiful stripped out like kind of slow version of 500 miles.
但他做了一个令人心碎、美丽、剥离出来的、慢速版的《500 Miles》。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
We should post that, Alec.
我们应该发布那个，亚历克。
We should put that in the notes.
我们应该把它放在笔记里。
I don't know that I don't remember that.
我不知道，我不记得那个了。
It made me so beautiful.
它让我觉得太美了。
And I and it was very moving to people that I put it on as the song of the day that day.
而且那天我把它作为每日一歌时，它非常打动人。
Yeah, totally.
是啊，完全是。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
That's make I'm having yet another pang of regret that we didn't think to do that late in series on How much mother, that would have been great.
这让我又产生了一种遗憾，我们没有想到在《老爸老妈浪漫史》后期做这件事，那会很棒的。
I don't know that.
我不知道。
Oh yeah, no, I guess it would have existed.
哦，是的，不，我想它应该已经存在了。
I think it had been released, like you might have actually locked the picture.
我想它已经发布了，就像你可能已经锁定了画面。
Just released.
刚发布。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
That's very cool.
太酷了。
Yeah, we also play the solids, our band that we still do an annual fundraiser concert of the music of how much mother we always play.
是的，我们还演奏“The Solids”，我们的乐队，我们仍然每年举办一场《老爸老妈浪漫史》音乐的筹款音乐会，我们总是演奏。
That song, edit, we were doing it at Bowery Ballroom again.
那首歌，编辑，我们又在Bowery Ballroom演奏了。
It's usually the closer, right?
通常是压轴曲目，对吧？
It's usually the closer people we bring everybody out.
通常是压轴，我们把大家都叫出来。
You've jumped out and sang on it.
你跳出来唱过。
Kristen Milleotti has Matthew Cos from Nada Surf.
克里斯汀·米利欧缇有来自Nada Surf的马修·卡斯。
We've had everybody come out and sing that song with our fans.
我们让所有人都出来和我们的粉丝一起唱那首歌。
I feel like Ashley Williams, like, really rocks out to it.
我觉得阿什利·威廉姆斯，就像，真的在那首歌里摇滚起来了。
She does, yeah.
她是，是的。
We really do.
我们确实如此。
We really have.
我们确实做到了。
So please, we will advertise when that show is.
所以请留意，我们会发布关于那场演出的公告。
It's going to be in June this year, come sing 500 Miles with us in person.
演出定于今年六月，欢迎亲自来和我们一起唱《500 Miles》。
All right.
好的。
We've got two letters here.
我们这里有两封信。
You guys want to take one, one, then the other?
你们想一人读一封吗？
Okay.
好的。
This letter is from Ross P and it says the following, Hello, Josh and Craig, I've been specifically waiting for this episode.
这封信来自Ross P，内容如下：嘿，Josh和Craig，我一直在专门等这一集。
you see, I own a Fierro.
你们看，我有一辆Fiero。
And for those of you who are wondering how reliable a Fierro, for those of you who are wondering how reliable a Fierro actually is, it is not.
对于那些想知道Fiero到底有多可靠的人，我想说，它一点也不可靠。
Well, pause now and say that Fierro's is they're not a sponsor.
好吧，先暂停一下，声明Fiero并不是我们的赞助商。
No, sadly, really, after this, does it still exist?
不，可悲的是，真的，在这之后，它还存在吗？
Do they still make Fierro's?
他们还在生产Fiero吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
That's a great question.
这是个好问题。
Alec, can you while I'm reading this letter look up of when Fierro's ceased to be made, which I feel like it was a while ago, and less, and then it's even worse slander if it, if I'm saying they're not made anywhere and are, so we'll edit this all out.
Alec，在我读这封信的时候，你能查一下Fiero是什么时候停产的吗？我觉得是很久以前的事了，如果我还在说他们没在生产，那简直是在造谣，所以我们到时候会把这些剪掉。
Here we go.
开始了。
Back to Trashing Fieros via Raspi.
回到通过Raspi吐槽Fiero的话题。
This episode of Hymian was actually the first episode of the show I ever saw.
《How I Met Your Mother》的这一集其实是我看过的第一集。
As I was looking for a YouTube video about Fieros, I stumbled upon a clip from this episode and decided I would watch it.
当时我在YouTube上搜索关于Fiero的视频，偶然发现了这一集的片段，于是决定看一看。
As you can imagine, having not seen any of the previous episodes, I was very confused and just assumed Lillian Robin were super enthusiastic about origami.
你们可以想象，因为没看过之前的剧集，我当时非常困惑，还以为Lillian和Robin对折纸艺术超级狂热。
I'm currently a sophomore in in Michigan, and I'm very happy, but before college, I was nervous about it.
我现在是密歇根州的一名大二学生，过得很开心，但在上大学之前，我对此感到很紧张。
As an Oklahoman, my college plan required that I pick up everything and move.
作为一个俄克拉荷马人，我的大学计划要求我收拾行囊，搬到外地。
It was an all-new experience with an all-new location and all-new people, and I wanted something that I knew, something that reminded me of who I was, as I was bombarded with new things, like Marshall, so I took my Fierro.
那是一个全新的环境、全新的地点和全新的人，我想要一些我熟悉的东西，一些能提醒我我是谁的东西，因为我当时被各种新事物轰炸，就像Marshall一样，所以我带上了我的Fiero。
The first week of college was difficult, and meeting new people was not my specialty, nor was it going well.
大学第一周很艰难，结识新朋友不是我的强项，进展也不顺利。
on my first weekend at college, I got in my Fierro and drove as far from campus as I could, but I only made it about 30 minutes before my Fierro's engine turned off and would not turn back on.
在大学的第一个周末，我坐进我的Fiero，尽可能地远离校园，但只开了大约30分钟，我的Fiero引擎就熄火了，再也发动不起来。
I was obviously devastated, however, just like Marshall's Fierro gave him a token of appreciation in its final moments.
我显然崩溃了，然而，就像Marshall的Fiero在最后时刻给了他一份感激的礼物一样。
I too was given a gift before my poor car was diagnosed with engine failure.
在我的破车被诊断出引擎故障之前，我也收到了一份礼物。
I was given my very first friends at college.
我得到了我在大学里的第一批朋友。
Having been stranded in the middle of nowhere, Michigan, I called the number of the only person I had talked to at any length during my first week.
被困在密歇根州荒无人烟的地方，我拨通了我在第一周里唯一聊过天的人的电话。
And she and some of her friends came and picked me up.
她和她的几个朋友过来接了我。
So in place of a cassette tape, I was given my first three friends.
所以，我得到的不是一盘磁带，而是我的前三个朋友。
And so when I watched this episode and I mourn for my car alongside Marshall, I drank a hypothetical celebratory beer.
所以当我看到这一集，和Marshall一起为我的车哀悼时，我喝了一杯假设性的庆祝啤酒。
I'm not 21 yet, huh?
我还没满21岁，哈？
Thanks for creating a show that makes friends so desirable and stories so much more fun to tell.
感谢你们创作了一部让友谊变得如此令人向往、让故事变得如此有趣的剧集。
Sincerely, Ross P and gray letter.
诚挚的，Ross P，一封很棒的信。
What a gray letter.
多棒的一封信啊。
Yeah.
是啊。
Awesome.
太棒了。
Love that.
喜欢这个。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you, Ross, and RIP your Fierro.
谢谢你，Ross，愿你的Fiero安息。
I know.
我知道。
RIP.
安息吧。
The last of which rolled off the lines on August 16th, 1988, two days shy of Fred's 13th birthday.
最后一辆车是在1988年8月16日下线的，离Fred的13岁生日还差两天。
I'm funny.
我真幽默。
We're like, oh, don't offend the Fierro makers.
我们当时还在想，哦，别冒犯了Fiero的制造商。
They haven't been at it since 1988.
他们从1988年起就不干这行了。
I would have guessed like the 90s or early 2000s.
我本来会猜是90年代或2000年代初。
I did not realize it went, I mean, I guess we know why.
我没意识到它停产那么早，我是说，我想我们知道原因。
They're not the most reliable car, but they looked cool and there's a cool name.
它们不是最可靠的车，但它们看起来很酷，而且名字也很酷。
So.
所以。
I bet for car people, like for real car people, my friend Kia is like a car guy.
我敢打赌，对于爱车人士，比如我朋友Kia，他是个车迷。
I bet fieros are like some of the most fit.
我敢打赌Fiero是那种最……
Like you spot a fiero and you're a car person.
就像你看到一辆Fiero，如果你是个车迷。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
You'd be thrilled.
你会很兴奋。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全同意。
How did you land on fiero?
你们是怎么选定Fiero的？
Like where'd that come from?
那是怎么来的？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Maybe it was Chris's choice.
也许是Chris的选择。
I think we just wanted something that was very dated and turns out to even be old in the 90s, right?
我想我们只是想要一些非常过时，甚至在90年代就已经很老的东西，对吧？
When Marshall got this in the early mid 90s from his brothers, it didn't stop being made years earlier.
当Marshall在90年代中期从他兄弟那里得到这辆车时，它已经停产好几年了。
I think we're looking for something that was old and kind of cool.
我想我们是在找一些既老又有点酷的东西。
And it was also like cool at one moment and just like, yeah.
而且它在某个时刻确实很酷，然后就……是啊。
I think just the name, honestly, the name Firo.
我觉得就是名字，老实说，Fiero这个名字。
It's just a cool name.
这名字真的很酷。
It was maybe not the, it's like Baba Garniz.
也许不是……就像Baba Garniz。
If you're going to say that over a lot of times make the title, it's got to be a cool word.
如果你要反复说它，把它作为标题，它必须是一个很酷的词。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, if you want, we have one more letter to read that's terrific.
好吧，如果你愿意，我们还有最后一封很棒的信要读。
But if you want to share your own Fiero memories or how I met your mother memories related anything to the show that you, why you watch it, why you love it, what has stayed with you all these years, please reach out to us at how we made your mother.com, hwmym.com, to contact and follow the instructions.
但如果你想分享你自己的Fiero回忆，或者与这部剧相关的《How I Met Your Mother》回忆，比如你为什么看它，为什么喜欢它，这些年来有什么一直留在你心中，请通过howimetyourmother.com，hwmym.com联系我们，并按照说明操作。
You can leave us a written note, you can leave us a voice note, and maybe we'll play at the beginning of the show.
你可以给我们留书面留言，也可以留语音留言，也许我们会在节目开头播放。
We love hearing from you guys.
我们很喜欢听你们分享。
And here is another Areva Deirci Fierro related note.
这里还有另一封关于Fiero的信。
This one's from Avery.
这封来自Avery。
Dear Craig and Josh, I want to start by taking you back to season two, episode 17, Areva Deirci Fierro.
亲爱的Craig和Josh，我想先带你们回到第二季第17集《Arrivederci, Fiero》。
In that episode, we learned how a beat-up old Fierro became the vehicle literally and and figuratively for Ted and Marshall's friendship.
在那一集中，我们了解了一辆破旧的Fiero是如何在字面意义和象征意义上成为Ted和Marshall友谊的载体。
Those road trips, singing along to, I'm gonna be 500 miles, created a bond that transcended the miles traveled.
那些公路旅行，一起唱着《I'm Gonna Be (500 Miles)》，建立了一种超越了行驶里程的纽带。
I'm writing to you because my own life has a red Mustang version of that story.
我写信给你们是因为我自己的生活中也有一个红色野马版的故事。
During my undergrad years at Marquette University in Milwaukee, my best friend Jake and I took countless road trips in his red Mustang.
在密尔沃基马凯特大学读本科期间，我和我最好的朋友Jake开着他的红色野马进行了无数次公路旅行。
Like Ted and Marshall in the Fierro, those drives became our sacred space, the place where a friendship transformed into brotherhood.
就像Fiero里的Ted和Marshall一样，那些旅程成了我们的神圣空间，友谊在那里升华为兄弟情谊。
And on those trips, windows down and the road stretching out before us, we bonded over our mutual love for how I met your mother.
在那些旅途中，摇下车窗，道路在我们面前延伸，我们因对《How I Met Your Mother》的共同热爱而结缘。
I came to Marquette carrying the weight of a difficult family situation.
我带着沉重的家庭负担来到马凯特大学。
Your show arrived in my life at exactly the right moment, offering something I desperately needed, a roadmap.
你们的剧集在我生命中最关键的时刻出现，提供了我迫切需要的东西：一张路线图。
You taught me that family isn't just who you're born to, it's the people you choose, the ones who show up for you and your best times and stand beside you through your worst.
你们教会我，家人不仅仅是血缘关系，更是你选择的人，是那些在你最美好的时光里为你喝彩，在你最糟糕的时刻站在你身边的人。
The gang at McLarens wasn't just a friend group, they were proof that you could build your own family.
McLaren酒吧里的那群人不仅仅是一个朋友圈，他们证明了你可以建立自己的家庭。
Jake became my brother and through him I found my own gang, a group of friends who were still my family to this day.
Jake成了我的兄弟，通过他，我找到了属于我自己的“帮派”，一群至今仍是我的家人的朋友。
We lived and breathed the show, we suited up, we accepted challenges.
我们沉浸在这部剧中，我们穿上西装，我们接受挑战。
How I met your mother wasn't just something we watched, it became the language through which we understood friendship, love and what it means to really show up for each other.
《How I Met Your Mother》不仅仅是我们看的一部剧，它成了我们理解友谊、爱情以及真正为彼此付出意味着什么的语言。
A few years after we graduated, I called Jake after my first date with a woman named Andrea.
毕业几年后，在我和一位名叫Andrea的女士第一次约会后，我给Jake打了电话。
We'd met at a cocktail lounge, ordered drinks and appetizers and talked for hours, and then it happened.
我们在一家鸡尾酒廊见面，点了饮料和开胃菜，聊了几个小时，然后事情发生了。
The olive theory right there on our first date, our appetizers arrived and without thinking she immediately reached for the olives while I instinctively pushed them aside.
就在第一次约会上，橄榄理论出现了：我们的开胃菜端上来时，她没多想就直接去拿橄榄，而我本能地把它们推到一边。
We both stopped, looked at each other and laughed because we both knew what that meant.
我们都停了下来，看着对方，然后大笑，因为我们都知道这意味着什么。
It was such a small moment, but in that instant I knew I told Jake right then she was the one.
那只是一个小瞬间，但在那一刻，我知道了，我当时就告诉Jake，她就是那个人。
Your show became part of Andrea's and my love story from that very first date and earlier this year when we got married, Jake stood up as my best man and said, Andrea, to quote Avery's favorite show, How I Met Your Mother, You Pass the Front Porch Test.
你们的剧集从第一次约会起就成了我和Andrea爱情故事的一部分，今年早些时候我们结婚时，Jake担任了我的伴郎，他说：“Andrea，引用Avery最喜欢的剧《How I Met Your Mother》里的话，你通过了前廊测试。”
I'll see you guys on the porch in 50 years for our daily match of bridge.
500年后，我们会在前廊见面，每天打桥牌。
But beyond the laughs and the catchphrases your show taught me something profound.
但除了欢笑和口头禅，你们的剧集还教会了我一些深刻的东西。
It's okay to be vulnerable, it's okay to feel, it's okay to fail, because the best things in life are worth waiting for.
脆弱一点没关系，有感觉没关系，失败也没关系，因为生命中最美好的事物值得等待。
Looking back now, I'm grateful for every heartbreak, every hardship, every wrong turn, because they all led me to Andrea.
如今回首往事，我感激每一次心碎、每一次磨难、每一次走错路，因为它们最终都将我引向了安德莉亚。
They led me to the life I'm living now, married to the woman of my dreams.
它们将我引向了现在的生活，让我与梦中情人结为连理。
Now listening to how we made your mother, and hearing the behind the scenes stories of how you crafted these moments, I'm reminded all over again of the intentionality and heart you poured into every episode.
现在听着你们讲述《老爸老妈浪漫史》的制作过程，听着你们精心打造这些瞬间的幕后故事，我再次感受到你们倾注在每一集里的用心与深情。
It's been such a gift to revisit the show through your eyes.
能通过你们的视角重温这部剧，真是一份厚礼。
Thank you for creating something that became so much more than entertainment.
感谢你们创造了这样一部超越了娱乐本身的作品。
Thank you for giving someone navigating a difficult family situation, a vision of what shows and family looks like.
感谢你们为身处家庭困境的人们，提供了一幅关于剧集和家庭应有模样的愿景。
Thank you for the laughter, the tears and the belief that our stories, no matter how meandering, are leading us exactly where we need to be with immense gratitude, Avery.
感谢你们带来的欢笑、泪水，以及那份信念——无论我们的故事多么曲折，它们都在指引我们走向该去的地方。怀着无比的感激，艾弗里。
Fantastic.
太棒了。
It's so cool how this show has turned out.
这部剧能有今天这样的反响，真是太酷了。
The show about love has turned out to be a part of so many real-life love stories.
这部关于爱的剧集，最终成为了许多现实爱情故事的一部分。
It's really cool.
真的很酷。
I was thinking about this that we can talk about this if we talk about this more as the years go on.
我一直在想，随着岁月的流逝，如果我们能更多地谈论这一点就好了。
We talked about there was something about Ted that felt a little out of fashion or a little bit out of step with the times.
我们曾讨论过，泰德这个角色身上有些东西显得有点过时，或者说有点与时代脱节。
It was still like a real dudes, dudes on the air.
他依然像是个老派的家伙，那种在广播里说话的家伙。
And I always was like, I know I'm playing this very vulnerable guy who leads with his heart on the sleeve, his vulnerable feelings, but he's got this emotional resilience that I found to be very heroic and strong.
我一直觉得，虽然我扮演的是这个非常脆弱、总是真情流露的家伙，但他拥有一种情感韧性，我觉得这非常英勇且强大。
But it's so wonderful to hear a letter like that.
但能听到这样的来信真是太美好了。
He taught me it's okay to feel, it's okay to fail.
他教会了我，有感觉没关系，失败也没关系。
And that's That's why I think Ted and the show as a whole has aged pretty well, you know, there was some real, I don't know, there was just a feeling of like, like, stop, stop with this vulnerable guy.
这就是为什么我认为泰德以及整部剧经受住了时间的考验，你知道，当时确实有一种……我不知道，就是有一种感觉，好像在说“停下，别再演这个脆弱的家伙了”。
You guys even got notes from the network, like, you know, who would be like this?
你们甚至还收到过电视网的反馈，说“谁会像这样啊？”
And you're like, we're like this, you know, but it's just so nice to have it reflected back that our gamble on a character like this and paid off in ages as well because it's It's true.
而你们会说“我们就是这样啊”，但能得到这样的反馈，证明我们在这个角色上下的赌注得到了回报，而且经受住了时间的考验，因为这是事实。
Yeah.
没错。
It's the truth of how people are and how men are, you know, it's the pretending otherwise that seems to cause all the problems.
这就是人们和男人们真实的样子，你知道，假装不是这样反而才会导致所有的问题。
Yeah.
没错。
Well, thanks, Avery.
好吧，谢谢你，艾弗里。
Thanks, Ross.
谢谢你，罗斯。
We just loved reading those letters.
我们真的很喜欢读这些信。
Yeah.
没错。
That's great.
太棒了。
We love talking.
我们喜欢聊天。
I love talking about this episode.
我喜欢谈论这一集。
This was really fun, Craig.
这一集真的很有趣，克雷格。
Yeah.
没错。
So this is a great one.
所以这一集很棒。
Go Chris Harris.
克里斯·哈里斯加油。
Go everybody.
大家加油。
Everybody was firing on all cylinders except the Fierro.
除了菲耶罗，每个人都火力全开。
Boom.
砰。
And that's how you end an episode.
这就是结束一集的方式。
I am guilty.
我认罪。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·拉德诺和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies Network和Odyssey呈现并发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金赛。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我，亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point of Blue Studios的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美术设计由约翰·莫罗负责。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在Apple Podcasts或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分并评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约城》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德诺创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马尤斯基提供了额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问HowWeMajorMother.com了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
订阅乔什·拉德诺在Substack上的时事通讯，并在JoshRadner.com上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《那不是事情发生的方式》，各大书店均有销售，并可在CraigThomasWriter.com查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在Substack上订阅我自己的《死去的父亲协会》。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何做出改变的信息，以及本节目为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹款的持续活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签。
will, in fact, dance.
确实会跳舞。